तो चलिए गाइस स्टार्ट करते हैं आज के सेशन
को फटाफट से
लेकिन अभी आने अभी काफी लोग आए नहीं है
काफी लोग ने लाइव ने काफी लोगों ने लाइव
जॉइन नहीं करा है थोड़ा वेट कर लेते हैं
थोड़ा सा वेट कर लेते हैं सबको जवाइन करने
देते हैं लाइव एंड देन वी विल स्टार्ट तो
जल्दी आ जाओ सभी लोग जल्दी आ जाओ काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट क्लास है आज का काफी
इंपोर्टेंट सेशन है काफी शानदार सेशन है
काफी मजा आएगा आज के सेशन में आपको ठीक है
तो आ जाने देते हैं पहले सभी को ताकि कोई
कंप्लेन ना करे कि भैया हम आए नहीं उसके
पहले आपने क्लास शुरू कर दी यह बताइए
ऑडियो वीडियो सब सही
है ऑडियो वीडियो एकदम टकाटक है गाइस बता
दीजिए मुझे जो भी आ रहे हैं लाइक ठोकते
आइएगा एंड हेलो हेलो एवरी बडी
हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो नौसिखिया क्या बात है
नौसिखिया आपका नाम मुझे नहीं पता बट ठीक
है जो भी है आपका आई गट थ्री वने बिलिटी
p4 एंड प फाइव क्या बात है बहुत बढ़िया
बहुत बहुत बधाई हो कांग्रेचुलेशन नौ
सिखिया को तीन वने एबिलिटीज मिली है इनको
p4 एंड p5 की
दैट्ची वमेंटर सेल्फ एंड ये वलने बिलिटी
आपको रिवॉर्ड दे ना दे कोई मैटर नहीं करता
है हॉल ऑफ फेम दे ना दे मैटर नहीं करता है
बाउंट दे ना दे मैटर नहीं करता है वैलिड
अगर बग है तो वही मैटर करता है अभी जब आप
हर चीज स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं आपको एक
मोटिवेशन चाहिए तो मेनी मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशन ठीक है अ ठीक है बहुत
बढ़िया लगे रहो लगे रहो बहुत बढ़िया हेलो
रेड वन हेलो मोहित हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो
अयान बहुत बढ़िया अ नारायण ओके नारायण ठीक
है नारायण
अ ओके मुकुल ओके ग्रेट आई गॉट डुप्लीकेट
क्या बात है कोई बात नहीं डुप्लीकेट इज
जस्ट स्टार्ट ऑफ गेटिंग वैलिड लेबिलिटी तो
ये एक स्टार्ट है वैलिड लेबिलिटी पाने का
तो ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेनी आपको ठीक है
डुप्लीकेट्स आर अ वे टू सक्सेस सर एक्सेस
डिजिटल ओसन $ लाइफ टाइम यूजिंग गिट हब
डेवलपर यूजिंग यूनिवर्सिटी आईडी कार्ड
क्या बात है बिरबल मेनी मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशन
ब्रदर
अ आयन ग्राफिक्स थैंक यू सो मच सब पूछता
है कितनी फीस है तुम्हारी कोचिंग की तो
अयान बताते नहीं हो कितनी फीस है बता
बताना चाहिए अयान की कितने पैसे देक तुम
ये बग बाउंट सीख रहे हो यह तो बताना चाहिए
ना तुम्हें है ना बताओ उनको कि मैं 0.0
देके और इस तरह की चीजें सीख रहा हूं एंड
डि फ्रक्स अकेडमी से सीख रहा हूं बस इतना
ही बताओ
क्या यही तो क्वालिटी है यही तो बात है डि
फ्रक्स पे आपके आपको अगर कंटेंट जो मिलेगी
देखो कंटेंट आने में टाइम लग सकता है आई
एग्रीड कुछ गैप हो सकता अग्री बट जो
मिलेगा वो बेस्ट क्वालिटी मिलेगी बेस्ट ऑफ
द बेस्ट मिलेगी ठीक
है इज अ डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग लीगल
हां भाई बिल्कुल अगर आपके पास प्रोग्राम
का लाइक एक्सेप्टेंस है कि हां भैया आप
उसपे हंट कर सकते हो प्रोग्राम के साइड से
एंड ए आपके पास वो परमिशन है देन ओबवियसली
एवरीथिंग इज लीगल जब तक जिस प्रोग्राम का
आपके पास परमिशन है आप उस परे हंट कर सकते
हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है भैया ठीक है हेलो
सर आई एम न्यू टू साइबर सिक्योरिटी
वीडियोस आर सो हेल्पफुल थैंक यू अभिषेक
धन्यवाद हेलो दिव्यांश पुराने लोग कहां है
सब लोग हैं यहीं पे हैं दिव्यांश सब लोग
पुराने लोग आते हैं जाते हैं फिर नए लोग
भी आते हैं फिर जाते हैं सब आते जाते रहते
हैं सीखते रहते हैं हमारा काम सीखना है
ठीक है सर आपकी फर्स्ट टाइम लाइव अटेंड कर
रहा हूं इससे पहले रिकॉर्डेड देख रहा था
क्या बात है विराज लाइव अटेंड कर रहे हो
बहुत अच्छी बात है आज पता है ना बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है आज पता है ना
क्योंकि देखो आप में से कितने लोगों को
एकदम एग्जैक्ट सच सच बताना आप लोग में से
कितने लोगों को रिपोर्ट राइटिंग में
दिक्कत आती है ज आप बग तो फाइंड कर लोगे
वनबिल भी फाइंड कर लोगे एक टाइम पे बट
रिपोर्ट राइटिंग में आपकी रूह कांप जाती
है आपको लगता है ओ माय गॉड व्हाट टू डू
क्या करें अब रिपोर्ट कैसे लिखें कैसे
बढ़िया रिपोर्ट लिखे ताकि सामने वाला जो
ट्रायड टीम से है जो ट्रा करने के लिए
बैठा हुआ है जो आपके रिपोर्ट को एक्सेप्ट
करने के लिए बैठा है वो ज्यादा उसको
परेशानी ना हो और वो एक्सेप्ट कर ले अब
मैं आपको एक इसका सिंपल सा रीजन बताता हूं
सिंपल सा रीजन बताता हूं सुन लो अब देखो
ट्रैक टीम के साइड जो बैठा रहता है ना वो
भी एक रिसर्चर या एक सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर
होता है या एथिकल हैकर होता है राइट वो
अपनी जॉब कर रहा होता है सिंपल सा फंड है
उसको जॉब करनी है एक उस कंपनी के लिए ठीक
है और कुछ नहीं करना है अब वो जॉब कर रहा
है हो सकता है उसका जब आपके आपका रिपोर्ट
वो अ रिव्यू कर रहा हो उसके पहले क्या
सिचुएशन उस टाइम में क्या सिचुएशन नोबडी
नोज उसका माइंड का स्टेट क्या है किसी को
नहीं पता है ठीक है सब उसके हाथ में है
पहली बात ठीक है एट द फर्स्ट टाइम अब आपने
आपने रिपोर्ट लिखा आपने रिपोर्ट काम चलाऊ
रिपोर्ट लिख दिया आपने क्या लिखा काम चलाऊ
रिपोर्ट लिख दिया अब वो लेके बैठ गया अब
देख रहा है इधर से रीप्रोड्यूस करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है उधर से कर रहा है अब उस
वो
रिप्रोडक्टिव इसको इसको गोली मारते हैं
इसको इसको छोड़ ही दो तो आपकी वहां पे जो
बग जो रिपोर्टिंग आपने करी है ना उसका कोई
मतलब नहीं रह जाएगा एंड वो आपका रिजेक्ट
हो जाता है ठीक है हालांकि अगर आपका वैलिड
बग है अगर आपका बग
रिप्रोडक्टिव अपन कर दोगे फिर दूसरा
रिसर्चर भी आ उसपे एक बार ट्राई देखेगा
अगर
रिप्रोडक्टिव
अ रिपोर्ट व्हाट अ फैंटास्टिक रिपोर्ट
व्हाट अ शानदार रिपोर्ट ऐसा होना चाहिए कई
बार हैकर वन पे आपने देखा होगा कई सारी
रिपोर्ट्स अगर आप में से कोई रिपोर्ट
पढ़ता होगा हैकर वन के तो मैं उनको बता
रहा हूं ठीक है अगर आपने रिपोर्ट पढ़ा
होगा तो उन रिपोर्ट्स में कई ऐसे
रिपोर्ट्स होते हैं गाइस मेनी ऑफ द
रिपोर्ट जिसमें कि ट्रैक टीम के तरफ से या
उस प्रोग्राम की तरफ से काफी एप्रिसिएशन
किया जाता है उस रिसर्चर को कि इतनी डिटेल
और इतनी अच्छी रिपोर्ट आपने लिखी है कि हम
इजली इसको रीप्रोड्यूस कर पा रहे थे इजली
हम इस तक पहुंच गए एंड हम जो है इसको
मिटिगेट कर पाए बहुत सारे रिसर्चस मिटिगेट
का भी जो स्टेप है वो भी लिख देते हैं
मिटिगेशन कि भैया ये मिटिगेशन स्टेप होना
चाहिए ये इस तरीके से आप मिटिगेट कर
पाएंगे तो ये और भी उनका काम जो है आसान
बना देता है तो इस तरीके की चीजें होती
हैं एंड बग बाउंट हंटिंग करने के पूरी
प्रोसेस में इस रिपोर्ट राइटिंग का सबसे
बड़ा रोल है आपकी रिपोर्ट कई बार मेनी
टाइम्स रिपोर्ट अच्छी ना होने की वजह से
रिजेक्ट हो जाएगी एंड अगर वैलिड वर्ग होगा
भी तो भी वो इंपैक्टफुल नहीं दिखेगा बिकॉज
आपने बहुत ही पुअर एक रिपोर्ट लिखी है तो
आज की इस सेशन में हम पूरा कंप्लीट एक
अच्छे से रिपोर्ट राइटिंग को देखने वाले
हैं किस तरीके से रिपोर्ट को हम लिखें
ताकि व उस पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम के तरफ से या उस प्लेटफार्म पे
एक्सेप्ट हो या होने के चांसेस मैक्सिमम
हो उस रिपोर्ट के ठीक है तो यह हम देखने
वाले हैं ठीक है
चलिए चलिए तो अब हम स्टार्ट करते हैं क्या
वर्चुअल अभी मैं चैट प ध्यान नहीं दे रहा
हूं तो एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी चलो एक बार देख लेते हैं गुड इवनिंग
सर आई एम करेंटली ऑन डे करेंटली डे एंड
टिल नाउ आ एवरीथिंग इज क्रिस्टर क्लियर
नाउ इ गोइंग टू स्टार्ट डे सिक्स लव योर
इन डेप्थ टीचिंग मेथड थैंक यू थैंक यू
ब्रदर थैंक यू बहुत बढ़िया फर्स्ट क्लास
ऑन लाइव क्या बात है केविन साइबर वरियर
ग्रेट बहुत बढ़िया फर्स्ट क्लास इनका लाइव
है बहुत अच्छी बात
है
अ सर वीपीटी कोर्स में डॉस एंड डीडियोस
अटैक टॉपिक एंड बटने अटैक कोर्स में है
क्या सब कुछ आपको ऑलरेडी
whatsapp2 ट्रेनिंग है उसकी पूरी जो
सिलेबस है वो ऑलरेडी प्रोवाइड कर दी गई है
अगर आपको नहीं पता
whatsapp2 वीडियो के या इस वीडियो के भी
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइए वहां
whatsapp2 पे सारी अपडेट्स आपको मिलती
रहती है और ये हमारी डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के लिंकडन पेज है हमारी कंपनी
की पेज है कंपनी से रिलेटेड जो भी अपडेट्स
जो भी फ्यूचर में हम काम कर रहे होंगे किस
तरीके से डेनिक्स को हम आगे लेकर जा रहे
हैं एक स्टार्टअप से एक मल्टीनेशनल कंपनी
बनाने की एक हमारी जो कोशिश है वो कैसे जा
रही है एक बड़ी कंपनी एक बिगेस्ट साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कंपनी बनाने की एक कोशिश वो
किस तरीके से आगे हम लेकर जा रहे हैं वो
सारी अपडेट्स आपको इसी पेज पे मिलने वाली
है अपकमिंग कोर्सेस ट्रेनिंग सर्विसेस हर
एक चीज प्रोडक्ट के बारे में भी आपको यहां
जानकारी मिलेगी तो उसको फॉलो करके रखिएगा
ठीक है तो चलिए अब जो है आज की सेशन जो है
वो शानदार तरीके से पहले हम समझ लेते हैं
एंड उसको हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ाते हैं
कंप्लीट याद रखिएगा आज का जो सेशन है आप
कंप्लीट लाइव अभी देखिए ज्यादा मजा आएगा
एंड इसी तरीके से आप रिपोर्ट्स बनाइए आने
वाले जो भी क्लासेस हैं सॉरी आने वाली जो
भी आपकी बाउंड बग्स मिलेंगे या बग्स आप
डिस्कवर कीजिएगा उसके लिए ठीक है आज का
सेशन ऑलमोस्ट एक घंटा ही चल चलेगा एक या
सवा घंटा या मैक्सिमम डेढ़ घंटा एंड उसमें
हम बहुत कुछ आज कवर करेंगे तो थोड़ा ध्यान
इधर देके चलिए एंड हम देखते हैं
बग बाउंट रिपोर्ट राइटिंग ठीक है आज के
सेशन का टॉपिक हमारा है बग बाउंट रिपोर्ट
राइटिंग ये भी रिपोर्ट राइटिंग कैसा किस
तरह का इसके स्टार्टिंग में जोड़ देते हैं
एक्सीलेंट
एक्सीलेंट बग बाउंडी रिपोर्ट राइटिंग मतलब
एक्सीलेंट लेवल का जो है बग बाउंट रिपोर्ट
राइटिंग हम करने वाले हैं अब देखो यहां पे
मेरे से काफी लोग बोलते हैं कि भैया ये
लाइक एक्सीलेंट एक्सीलेंट ई होता है क्या
हां भैया कि ये क्या-क्या स्टेप क्या-क्या
क्या-क्या चीजें होंगी अंदर में क्या-क्या
चीजें लिखनी पड़ेंगी क्या अब मैं मुझे एक
चीज नहीं समझ में आती हर एक चीज ना आपके
सामने है आप देख नहीं पा रहे हो आप नहीं
देख पा रहे हो आपको तो एक बहुत शानदार
स्टेप बताया गया है वह भी आपके सामने है
फ्री में पड़ा हुआ है आप नहीं देख पा रहे
हो यू कैन नॉट इमेजिन यू कैन नॉट सी यू
कैन नॉट यूटिलाइज दैट थिंग एंड सबसे पहले
हम स्टार्ट करते हैं देखो हर प्लेटफॉर्म
पे आप सिमिलर तरीके से रिपोर्टिंग कर सकते
हो सिमिलर तरीके से या अगर कोई ऐसा
प्रोग्राम है जिसको आपने
google2 प्रोग्राम है जो हैकर वन ब क्राउड
इन सब पे नहीं है आपको डायरेक्ट वहां पे
रिपोर्ट करनी है तो भी आप यही स्टेप्स
लिखोगे एंड इन्हीं तरीके से जो है आप आगे
बढ़ो ग पर्टिकुलर इन रिपोर्टिंग द अ
पर्टिकुलर वल एबिलिटी चलिए अब यहां पे
शुरू करने से पहले कुछ चीजें हम पहले
देखते हैं सबसे पहले एक चीज मैं आपको
बताता हूं वह है सीवीएसएस
स्कोर सीवीएसएस स्कोर पहले हम इसको थोड़ा
सा देख लेते हैं यह क्या होता है सीबीएसएस
स्कोर वो हम थोड़ा सा समझते हैं ठीक है
चलिए तो सीबीएसएस स्कोर का मतलब होता है
कॉमन वल्नरेबल स्कोरिंग सिस्टम ओके कॉमन
वनबिल स्कोरिंग सिस्टम अब भैया यह क्या है
यार कॉमन वनबिल स्कोरिंग सिस्टम तो ये
क्या है इज अ पब्लिक फ्रेमवर्क फॉर रेटिंग
द सीवियरिंग एंड कैरेक्टरिस्टिक ऑफ
सिक्योरिटी वनबिल इन इंफॉर्मेशन सिस्टम बस
यही है कि भैया किस तरह का यह वनबिल है
पर्टिकुलर किस तरह की इसकी रेटिंग दी गई
है क्या इसका रेटिंग है किस तरीके से है
वह सारा कुछ यहां से कैलकुलेट होता है अब
यहां पे सीबीएसएस स् कोर्स आर कैलकुलेटेड
यूजिंग अ फार्मूला कंसिस्टिंग ऑफ वनबिल
बेस्ड मैट्रिक्स अ सीवीएसएस स्कोर इज
डराइड फ्रॉम स्कोर्स इन दीज थ्री मैट्रिक
ग्रुप्स क्या होता है एक बेस टेंपोरल एंड
एनवायरमेंट ये तीन मैट्रिक्स ग्रुप्स में
डिवाइड होते हैं अब इसमें एक रेंज होता है
स्कोर का क्या रेंज होता है 0 से 10 तक
जीरो का मतलब लिस्ट जो वल्नरेबल सॉरी
लिस्ट जो आपका सीवियर वल्नरेबल है वो और
10 का मतलब क्या हो जाता है तो हाईएस्ट
सीवियर वनबिल है उसको हम 10 बोलते हैं ठीक
है ये सब कुछ मिला के आपका वो होता है अब
बेस मैट्रिक्स क्या होता है द बेस स्कोर
इज द मेट्रिक एंटरप्राइजेस रिला अपऑन
मोस्ट इट डील्स विद द इन्हेरेंट
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक ऑफ अवेलेबिलिटी इन्हेरेंट
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक जो है लेबिलिटी का उस पे
ये टोटली जो होता है उससे डील उसपे डील अ
हम करते हैं एंड दैट इज द वंस दैट डोंट
चेंज ओवर टाइम और ड्यू टू अ यूजर्स
एनवायरमेंट पब्लिक सीवियरिंग सच एज दोज
फाउंड इन नेशनल इंस्टिट्यूट ऑफ
स्टैंडर्ड्स एंड टेक्नोलॉजी जो एनआईए एसटी
फ्रेमवर्क की बात कर रहे हैं एंड नेशनल
वनबिल डेटाबेस जो कि हम व डेटाबेस जो
बोलते हैं एक्सल एक्सक्लूसिवली पर्टन टू
बेस सीवीएस स् कोल चलिए अब यहां पे देखिए
यहां पे अलग-अलग जो है दो मैट्रिक्स दिए
गए हैं जिसके अंदर में क्या होता है अ
कुछ-कुछ जो अ एंटिटी है वो फॉल करती है
जैसे एक्सप्लोइटेबल मैट्रिक्स एक होता है
एक इंपैक्ट मैट्रिक्स होता है अब एक्सप्लो
बिलिटी मैट्रिक्स जो है इसके अंदर क्या
होता है अटैक वेक्टर होता है अटैक
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड रिक्वायर्ड होता है यूजर
इंटरेक्शन होता है समझ में आया मतलब ये जो
मैट्रिक्स है ये एक्सप्लोइटेबल मैट्रिक्स
है एंड इसके अंदर कोई मान लो लेबिलिटी है
उसमें यूजर इंटरेक्शन हो रहा है तो वो
इसके अंदर में फॉल करेगी प्रिविलेज चाहिए
प्रिविलेज चाहिए यूजर का नॉर्मल यूजर नहीं
प्रिविलेज यूजर का चाहिए तो इसमें करेगा
अटैक
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड वेक्टर के ऊपर इसके ऊपर आ
जाता है इंपैक्ट मैट्रिक्स में क्या आ
जाता है कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी इंटीग्रिटी एंड
अवेलेबिलिटी यानी कि इंपैक्ट मैट्रिक्स
सीआईए ट्रायड को हम बोल सकते हैं सीआईए
ट्रेड जो आपने पढ़ा होगा शायद सीआईए
ट्राइड हमारे जो स्टूडेंट्स होंगे यहां पे
डीसी जीएसपी के उनको सीआईए ट्राइड के बारे
में काफी ज्यादा अच्छे से नॉलेज होगी काफी
डीप नॉलेज होगी क्योंकि काफी अच्छे से
एक्सप्लेंड है उसमें ठीक है डीसी जीएसपी
में नाउ यहां पे अब टेंपोरल मैट्रिक्स ये
जो आपका था बेस मैट्रिक्स की हम बात कर
रहे थे अब आते हैं यहां पे टेंपोरल
मैट्रिक्स यहां पे चीज हैं आप इसको पढ़
लीजिएगा बहुत ज्यादा डिटेल में जाना
पड़ेगा इसके अंदर में आप पढ़ लीजिएगा समझ
में आ जाएगा उसके बाद एनवायरमेंट
मैट्रिक्स जो है वो आती है ठीक है उसी
तरीके से यहां पे आप नेशनल वनबिल डेटाबेस
के ऊपर आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे वनबिल
मैट्रिक्स के बारे में अगेन पूरा डिटेल
यहां पे दिया हुआ है एंड यहां पे आप यहां
पे देख सकते हैं कि ये जो क्वालिटेटिव सटी
सीवियरिंग रेटिंग्स है इसको कैसे डिवाइड
किया गया है अब ये आप देख लीजिए जैसे
सीवीएसएस अगर मान लो वर्जन 2.0 रेटिंग्स
को देखें तो ये डिवाइड था 3.1 में ये था
एंड 4.0 जो वर्जन इसका आया हुआ है उसमें
क्या है भैया ये वाली रेटिंग है अब इसमें
रेटिंग क्या है आप य ये देखिए मतलब इसमें
रेटिंग क्या है देखिए
सवेरिन अगर कोई ऐसी वनबिल जिसकी सीवियरिंग
कुछ नहीं है उसको जो स्कोर मिलेगा जीरो
मिलेगा अगर कोई ऐसा वल्नरेबल
जिसकी सीवियरिंग है लो तो उसको जो उसकी जो
स्कोर की रेंज होगी वोह 0.1 से लेके 3.9
तक ये रेंज होगी मीडियम की रेंज 4 से 6.9
तक होगी हाई की रेंज 7 टू 8.9 होगी और
क्रिटिकल की 99.0 से 10 होगी यानी कि अगर
मान लो बाय चांस आपको कोई वल्नरेबल बहुत
एक क्रिटिकल वल्नरेबल मान लो स्किल
इंजेक्शन कहीं मिल जाता है आरसी कहीं मिल
जाती है दिस इज़ अ मोस्ट दिस इज ऑटोमेटिक
कंसीडर्ड एज अ क्रिटिकल वल बिलिटी क्योंकि
आप आर्बिट्री कोड एग्जीक्यूट कर पा रहे हो
आप डेटाबेस टम कर पा रहे हो दिस इज़ द
क्रिटिकल वलने बिलिटी तो आप क्या बोल सकते
हो कि आई फाउंड अ क्रिटिकल वनबिल या तो आप
क्या बोलोगे आई फाउंड अ वनबिल विद
सीबीएसएस स्कोर 9 टू 10 एज सिंपल ए दोनों
बात सेम है तो अब यह जो तुम बोलोगे सीवीएस
स्कोर 9 टू 10 वाली वलने बिलिटी मुझे मिली
है तो यह एक हाई टेक्निकल टर्म हो गया
थोड़ा सा टेक्निकल हो गया अरे सीवीएस
स्कोर 9 टू 10 वाली वलने बिलिटी तो सामने
वालो को लगेगा यू आर अ टेक्निकल पर्सन
थोड़ा लगेगा क्रिटिकल भी चल रहा है
क्रिटिकल चलता है यही चलता है जनरली वैसे
सीबीएस स्कोर में कोई ज्यादा बातें नहीं
करते हैं ज्यादातर वो लेकिन आप बोलोगे तो
थोड़ा सा फील आएगा आपको बस ये चीज है तो
ये एक डिविडेशन है मतलब डिवाइड करने का एक
तरीका हुआ है सीवियरिंग के बेसिस पे एक
तरह से क् अलग-अलग वनबिल को जो है वो
क्लासिफाई कर दिया गया है ठीक है
क्लासिफाई करके इस तरीके से यहां पे बता
दिया गया है अब यहां पे एक मैं आपको इमेज
दिखाना चाहूंगा इफ वी फाउंड
हा यह वाली यह इमेज है इसको आप देख सकते
हैं दिस इज अ गुड इमेज आपको समझना अगर
समझना है तो एंड ये सीवीएस स्कोर
मैट्रिक्स जो है 3.0 तक है ये बाकी इमेज
को आप देख के यहां पे समझ सकते हैं बेसिक
एंड टेंपोरल एंड एनवायरमेंट मैट्रिक्स
ग्रुप का जो भी डिटेल है वो समझ सकते हैं
ठीक है तो यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
अब इसको समझाने के पीछे रीजन था वो अभी
मैं आपको आऊंगा तो अभी बताऊंगा कि क्या
रीजन था इसका भी आपको सामने देखने को
मिलेगा तो सबसे पहले हम चलते हैं कि इसको
समझते हैं कि एक्चुअली ये कैसे रिपोर्टिंग
काम करती है इसके ऊपर में रिपोर्ट हमें
कैसे करना है किस तरीके से रिपोर्ट ऐसा
रिपोर्ट करना है कि भैया मजा आ जाए सामने
वाले ट्रैक टीम को सामने वाले रि सिक्योर
जो भी आपका सिक्योरिटी टीम है उस कंपनी का
उस प्रोग्राम का उसको मजा आना चाहिए फिर
आपका रिपोर्ट बल्ले-बल्ले फिर आपका बांटी
100% रखा रहेगा रिवॉर्ड स्वैग सब रखा
रहेगा चलिए तो यहां पे मैं हैकर वन के
डैशबोर्ड पे हूं बेसिकली यहां पे ये
अपॉर्चुनिटी
यहां पे हम चलते हैं
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री यहां पे आ चुकी है
जिसको मान लो आपको किसी एक पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम में कोई वने एबिलिटी मिली है
मान लो कोई वलने एबिलिटी मिली है ठीक है
तो यहां पे आप फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं
जैसे कि जो भी जिस टाइप का आपको चाहिए
बाउंट चाहिए यहां पे आप आपका मैनेज बाय है
करवन चाहिए कोलैबोरेशन एक्टिव प्रोग्राम
जो भी है यहां पे ऐसे टाइप आप चूज कर सकते
हैं सीआई चाहिए डोमेन चाहिए एंड्र ऐप
चाहिए आओ पप चाहिए या एग्जीक्यूटेबल कोई
चाहिए या हार्डवेयर चाहिए अदर एसेट चाहिए
आईपी एड्रेस चाहिए स्मार्ट कांट्रैक्ट
चाहिए ब्लॉकचेन वगैरह का तो ये सब कुछ
यहां पे मिलेगा अब यहां पे मान लो मुझे एक
प्रोग्राम जिसमें कि मुझे वलने एबिलिटी
मिली है मान लो मुझे
करोगे जब भी रिपोर्ट करोगे याद रखना एक
चीज हमेशा कि बिना उसकी प्रोग्राम हाईलाइट
या उसकी जो स्कोप आइटम्स हैं या उस
प्रोग्राम की जो रिपोर्टिंग वनबिल
रिपोर्टिंग सिस्टम किस तरीके से
रिपोर्टिंग पॉलिसी जो है उसको बिना पढ़े
नहीं करोगे यह बहुत बड़ी गलती करते हैं
न्यू कमर्स जो होते हैं जो नए-नए अभी बग
बाउंट फील्ड में आए हैं नए-नए अभी
रिपोर्ट्स वगैरह अभी करना शुरू किया है
बाउंट लाइक बग्स फाइंड करना शुरू किया है
दे डू अ वेरी वेरी सिली मिस्टेक कि वो
क्या करते हैं उनको कोई मान लो एक्सएसएस
मिल गया लेट्स सपोज एक्सएसएस मिल गया या
सीएसआरएफ मिल गया पट से गए रिपोर्ट
राइटिंग सबमिट रिपोर्ट कट कट कुछ कुछ डाल
दिया और सबमिट कर दिया गया गया वो खत्म हो
सकता है वो आपका कंसीडर ना हो उसके भी
रीजन है मैं आपको बताता हूं अब यहां पे
प्रोग्राम के बारे में पहले देखिए कि
प्रोग्राम कैसा है अब ये तो पॉपुलर
प्रोग्राम है
दे पे गुड बाउंटीज एंड दे देयर रिस्पांस
रेट इज क्वाइट गुड एंड दे रिस्पेक्ट द
रिसर्चस टाइम एंड दे वैल्यू देम ठीक है तो
ऐसे रि ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स प हंट करना चाहिए
कुछ हंटर्स क्या होते हैं न्यू कमर्स
बेसिकली मैं न्यू कमर्स की बात कर रहा हूं
जब भी अभी बात कर रहा हूं वह ऐसे
प्रोग्राम्स में हंट भी करते हैं जिनके
तरफ से उनको अच्छा ना तो रिस्पांस आता है
और जिनके तरफ से जो है वो एक स्कैम चल रहा
होता है दे आर डूइंग काइंड ऑफ सम स्कैम
ऐसे भी बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स है ठीक है
अब वैसे प्रोग्राम पे ना आपको टाइम वेस्ट
नहीं करनी है कई सारे आप प्रोग्राम्स पे
वनबिल रिपोर्ट करोगे ना बार-बार बोलेंगे
कि डुप्लीकेट बार-बार बोलेंगे कि अरे ये
तो डुप्लीकेट है पहले रिसर्चर ने सबमिट कर
दिया अरे ये तो डुप्लीकेट है बार-बार हर
एक लेबिलिटी को रिपोर्ट एक रिपोर्ट करने
पे ये बोलेंगे अभी
सिक्योरिटी डिपार्टमेंट डिपार्टमेंट ने सब
डोमेन टेकओवर को डुप्लीकेट बता दिया सब
डोमेन टेकओवर को डुप्लीकेट बताया है समझ
में आ रहा है तुम लोगों को मैं क्या कह
रहा हूं आपको आईडिया लग रहा है सब डोमेन
टेकओवर को डुप्लीकेट बताने का मतलब क्या
होता है व्हाट इज द मीनिंग व्हाट इज द
लॉजिक मतलब आपको समझ में आ रहा है कि सब
डोमेन टेकओवर को डुप्लीकेट क्यों नहीं
बताया जा सकता है अगर किसी रिसर्चर को सब
डोमेन टेकओवर मिला है इट कैन नॉट बी अ
डुप्लीकेट अब बताइए मुझे
हां पल्लव बिल्कुल सही बोल रहे हो तुम मैं
नाम नहीं ले सकता इसलिए मैंने बोला नहीं
लेकिन बिल्कुल सही बोल
रहे बिल्कुल सही अब मुझे आप
बताओ आप मुझे हां राइट राइट आपने पढ़ा था
बहुत अच्छी बात है आपको यह समझ में आ रहा
है ना आपको यह समझ में आ रहा है कि क्यों
नहीं बता सकते इसको
डुप्लीकेट बताइए मुझे चैट में बताइए आप
लोग किसको किसको समझ में आ रहा है समझ में
आ रहा है कि क्यों बता नहीं सकते इसको
डुप्लीकेट क्यों नहीं बता सकते व्हाई वी
कैन नॉट ट्रीट इट एज
डुप्लीकेट ऐसी कंपनी तिल चट्टा होता है
वाह यार क्या बात है
अ रेयर वनबिल है नहीं नहीं रेयर वनबिल है
इसके कारण नहीं नहीं
नहीं हेलो सर प्लीज एक्सप्लेन योर कोर्स
इन डिटेल्स कोर्स के बारे में क्या जानना
है कोर्स के बारे में तो यार तुम इस पे
चले जाना इस वाले यूआरएल पे चले जाना
de.com साइबर सिक्योरिटी मास्ट कोर्स इस
पर आ जाना इसको स्क्रॉल करके देख लेना
यहां से क्लिक करके नरोल भी कर सकते हो
ठीक है सिंपल एक्सेस वेब एंड प पे दोनों प
मिल जाएगा हां मुझे
बताइए आई वांट टू सब डोमेन टेकओवर सर
इंपैक्ट तो हाई है हां इंपैक्ट तो हाई
रहता है सही र ठीक है 500 भी मिल जाएगी
बाउंट तो अगर सही से हो तो सी नेम एड्रेस
बिल्कुल सही देखो अब वही बात है आप लोगों
में से ना कई लोगों ने सब डोमेन टेकओवर
वाली आपने क्लास करी है जो मैंने सब डोमेन
टेकओवर वाली क्लास कराई थी बग बाउटी में
बताओ यह भी क्लास मैंने कराई हुई है खुद
ही नहीं करोगे तो कोई क्या कर सकता है
बताओ आप लोगों में से सब डोमन टेकओवर वाली
क्लास करी है कितने लोगों ने करी है सर
टुडे इज माय बर्थडे ओहो क्या बात है
हैप्पी बर्थडे निसर्ग बताइए सब डोमन
टेकओवर किसने किसने करी है निशा कुमावत
विश यू अ वेरी वेरी हैप्पी
बर्थडे हां तो अब मैं आपको बताता हूं कि
सब डोमेन टेकओवर को हम क्यों डुप्लीकेट
नहीं कर स नहीं कर सकते मान लो मेरे को एक
सब डोमेन टेकओवर मिला लेट्स सपोज आई फाउंड
अ सब डोमेन टेकओवर मैंने एक किसी
प्लेटफॉर्म पे एक सब डोमेन का टेकओवर
फाइंड किया ठीक है वह गिट हब से मैंने
फाइंड किया मान लो गिट हब का पेज था जो
यूज़ में सब कंपनी ने क्या किया था उस गिट
हब पेज को मतलब उसका सी एम रिकॉर्ड हटाया
नहीं था वह मुझे मिल गया अब मैं जब टेकओवर
करूंगा ना जब उस पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन के
लिए तो गिट हब पे जाके क्लेम करूंगा वह सब
डोमेन और वह सब डोमेन जब मैं एक बार क्लेम
कर चुका तो उस को वेरीफाई करते हैं समझ
में आ रहा है वी उसको वेरीफाई किया जाता
है उस पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन को उस सब डोमेन
को हम यहां पे सी नेम रिकॉर्ड के थ्रू
वेरीफाई करते
हैं सी नेम रिकॉर्ड के थ्रू वी वेरीफाई
दैट पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन हमने जब वो सब
डोमेन को क्लेम कर लिया एक बार ऑलरेडी
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ कि वो दूसरे किसी
रिसर्चस के पास क्लेमड नहीं है अगर हम कोई
मान लो कोई और रिसर्चर उसको क्लेम करके
रखा हुआ है तभी तो भाई डुप्लीकेट आएगा ना
मेरा अगर मैं रिपोर्ट करूंगा तो लेकिन अगर
मैं भी क्लेम कर लिया तो मुझे यह बताओ कि
एक सब डोमेन को दो बंदे कैसे क्लेम कर
लेंगे सीधी सी बात है कॉमन सी बात है
सोचने वाली बात है एक ही डोमेन है सब
डोमेन है हाउ टू रिसर्चस कैन क्लेम बोथ एट
अ टाइम पॉसिबल ही नहीं है जैसे ही मान लो
पहले वाले ने गिट अप पे ही क्लेम किया हुआ
है जाके उसने सब डोमेन डाला है अगर मैं
गया और पहले से क्लेमड है तो ट वहां पे
सीधा मना कर देगा डायरेक्टली इट विल
डिनायर कर देगा और अब तो खैर सी नेम
वेरिफिकेशन थ्रू डीएनएस आ चुका है इस चीज
को मिटिगेट करने के लिए काउंटर मेजर करने
के लिए सब डोमेन टेकओवर को बहुत सारे जो
बेसिकली पेजेस हैं बहुत सारे जो सर्विस
क्लाउड सर्विस प्रोवाइड करते हैं जिनका
यूज किया जाता है अलग-अलग एज अ थर्ड
पार्टी सर्विस जैसे गिट हब हो गया आपका
ठीक है या नेटलिफाई हो गया बहुत सारी
सर्विसेस होती है उन लोगों ने सिनेम
रिकॉर्ड को वेरीफाई करने के लिए डीएनएस के
थ्रू कर दिया है ताकि सब डोमेन टेकओवर
होही ना पाए लेकिन मैं तो उनकी बात कर रहा
हूं जहां पर पॉसिबल है मान लो जहां पॉसिबल
है उनकी बात करते हैं ना तो कैसे होगा यार
सोचने वाली कॉमन सी बात है समझ में आ रहा
है आपको बात मैं क्या बोलना चाह रहा हूं
आर यू गेटिंग
एवरीवन एवरीवन आर यू गेटिंग गाइस लेट मी
नो आर यू गेटिंग की मैं क्या बोल रहा
हूं सर डि फ्रक्स अकेडमी प एक्सप्लेन
पाइथन कोर्स इट इज इंक्लूडेड इन डीसी
जीएसपी नहीं डीसी जीएसपी में इंक्लूड नहीं
है वो सेपरेट है
ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है सो देयर कैन नॉट
बी अ डुप्लीकेट सबड मेंट टेकओवर ठीक है
भाई डुप्लीकेट नहीं हो सकता चलिए तो यहां
पे बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स ऐसे होते हैं जो
इस तरह के काम करते हैं उन प्रोग्राम से
बच जाइएगा उन प्रोग्राम्स प कभी भी अपना
टाइम वेस्ट मत कीजिएगा क्योंकि आपका टाइम
जो है वो ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है देन दैट
पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम और द बाउंट और व्हाट
एवर ठीक है आपका टाइम प्रेशियस है आप अपने
टाइम की रिस्पेक्ट खुद नहीं करोगे तो
सामने वाला रिस्पेक्ट नहीं करेगा तो यू
शुड रिस्पेक्ट योर टाइम एंड उस टाइम को आप
किसी अच्छे प्रोग्राम पे लगाइए चलिए तो अब
आते हैं रिपोर्ट राइटिंग पे वापस से तो
यहां पे
स्कोप एंड टारगेट ओवरव्यू है आप स्कोप एंड
टारगेट ओवरव्यू पढ़ लीजिएगा कि भैया
प्राइमरी टारगेट में क्या-क्या आता है कौन
सा डोमेन कौन सा सब डोमेन आता है
क्या-क्या चीजें आती हैं मोबाइल टारगेट्स
में क्या-क्या आती है वो सारी चीजें आप
पढ़ लीजिएगा उसके बाद यहां पे अ लाइक ओपन
सोर्स टारगेट्स जो है दिए गए हैं वो पढ़
लीजिएगा एंड देन यहां पे आउट ऑफ स्कोप
इसको जरूर पढ़ ली देखिए यहां लिखा हुआ है
प्लीज रीड देख रहा है इन्होंने
स्पेसिफिकली मेंशन करा है क्योंकि बहुत
ऐसे न्यू कमर्स होते हैं ना वो आउट ऑफ
स्कोप नहीं देखते हैं फट पट कहीं पे भी अब
यार एक बात बताओ आउट ऑफ स्कोप में क्या
दिया हुआ है
क ये आउट ऑफ स्कोप है अब इस पे तुम्हें
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन भी मिल जाए बाय चांस तो
दे आर नॉट लायबल टू गिव यू अ बाउंट हां एक
बार क्या होता है कई बार ऐसा कुछ डिफरेंट
सिनेरियो हुए हैं केसेस हुए हैं जहां आउट
ऑफ स्कोप डोमेन पे एक हैकर ने हंट किया और
उसको उसपे भी बाउंट मिल गई क्योंकि वह
हाईली सीवियर वनबिल थी एंड उस पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम जो पर्टिकुलर जो आपका स्कोप था
उसके कारण एक ऐसा स्कोप जो इन स्कोप आइटम
में था जो कि प्रोग्राम के किसमें था
एलिजिबल आइटम्स में था टू हंट ऑन वो
इफेक्ट हो रहा था वो इंपैक्ट उसपे इंपैक्ट
आ रही थी दैट व्हाई दे गिवन द बाउंट फॉर
दैट आउट बट जनरली आउट ऑफ स्कोप आइटम्स के
लिए आपको बाउंट रिवर्ड कुछ नहीं मिलेगा
यानी कि प्रोग्राम इज नॉट लायबल नॉट बाउंड
टू प्रोवाइड यू एनी बाउंट ऑन दैट
पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम ऑन दैट पर्टिकुलर
स्कोप ठीक है यह बात दिमाग में रखिएगा
फोकस एरिया याद रखिए जब भी फोकस एरिया में
जो जो चीजें मेंशन है आप इधर इधर आप लोग
देख लीजिए इधर आप लोग देख लीजिए इधर ध्यान
दीजिए अभी मैं चैट नहीं पढ़ रहा तो मैं
आपके जवाब नहीं दे पाऊंगा ठीक है चैट पे
लास्ट में आ जाऊंगा तो आपके जवाब में दे
दूंगा तो यहां पे चैट आप भेजेंगे तो मुझे
अभी नहीं पता चल पाएगा अब यहां पे फोकस
एरिया में जो जो वनबिल कीज यहां पे लिखी
गई है ट्राई कीजिए कि आपको इनमें से कुछ
अगर मिलता है तो ये फिर आंखें बंद कर
लीजिए आपको कुछ मिलता है तो आपको रिवॉर्ड
मिलेगी अंट्स दैट इज द डुप्लीकेट फिर अगेन
वही सब डोमेन टेक ओवर नहीं होना चाहिए भाई
यहां पे नहीं तो फिर गड़बड़ है ओके
तो यहां पे एक्सक्लूडेड सबमिशन ये जरूर
पढ़ लीजिएगा कि भैया क्या-क्या एक्सक्लूड
है यह पढ़ लीजिएगा डीओएस डिनायल ऑफ
सर्विसेस एक्सक्लूड है क्या भैया है यहां
पे ये देखो इंटरनल आईपी डिस्क्लोजर
एक्सक्लूडेड है इंटरनल आईपी डिस्क्लोज हो
भी रही है तो दे विल एक्सक्लूड दैट दे विल
नॉट इंटरटेन दैट अंट्स कि आप उसको यह दिखा
पाएं कि ये आईपी एड्रेस एक रनिंग सर्विस
की है एंड ये आपके इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को या
आपके पर्टिकुलर बिजनेस को इंपैक्ट कर सकते
हैं या जो भी कर सकती है इंपैक्टफुल हो
सकती है तब आप कर सकते हैं रिपोर्ट तब आप
बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं मैं यह कहना चाहता
हूं कि इन स्कोप या जो भी स्कोप आइटम्स है
उसमें जो भी लेबिलिटी है कोई भी तो आपको
जो भी यहां पे एक्सक्लूडेड वाले में है
उसपे कोई काम नहीं करना है आपको वो चीज
रिपोर्ट नहीं करनी है बट बाय चांस आपको
ऐसा लगता है कि कुछ ऐसी लेबिलिटी या कुछ
ऐसा रिपोर्ट है आपका जो उसके उस पर्टिकुलर
स्कोप को टारगेट करता है या उनके
पर्टिकुलर रिसोर्स को टारगेट करता है जो
उनके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट हो सकता है
इंपैक्टफुल आपका है तो आप कर सकते हैं
बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं एक ट्राई मार सकते
हैं जनरली आप इनको छोड़ दीजिएगा ठीक है बस
स सारा डिटेल पढ़ लीजिएगा यहां पे टॉप
हैकर्स की लिस्ट है इनकी अब यहां पे आते
हैं रिपोर्ट पे अब देखो इतना शानदार
रिपोर्ट का फॉर्मेट इन्होंने ही दे दिया
है कि तुम इसी का कॉपी करो ना चारों जगह
क्यों दिमाग लगा रहे हो इतना क्यों इतना
वीडियो देख रहे हो
पे एक एक घंटे की वीडियो बनाई है बिना
मतलब का मतलब रिपोर्ट राइटिंग पे एक एक
घंटे की मतलब मैं ये नहीं बोल रहा ये अपना
लाइव है वो रिकॉर्डेड की मैं बात कर रं
जिसमें सिर्फ कंटेंट होता है लाइव में तो
हम इधर-उधर भी बातें कर लेते हैं इधर-उधर
से टाइम अपना बहुत ज्यादा यूटिलाइज हो
जाता है तो हमें उतनी जरूरत नहीं है सबमिट
रिपोर्ट पे आ जाइएगा क्योंकि मैं बहुत
डिटेल में आपको बता रहा हूं तो थोड़ा
हमारा टाइम तो जाएगा ठीक है तो अब यहां पे
आइएगा सबमिट रिपोर्ट पे अब इसका जो
रिपोर्ट आप सबमिट करोगे सेम यही आपको पूरा
का पूरा जो लेआउट है आपको रखना है सेम
लेआउट यू हैव टू
दैट्ची करना है तो मैंने डोमेन किया अब
स्पेसिफिक कोई इनका सब डोमेन है उस पे है
या हम सारे डोमेन एंड सब डोमेन की बात कर
रहे हैं netflix.com की तो चलो मैं
netflix.com पे मुझे मिल रहा है मैंने
इसको सेलेक्ट किया यहां पे करंट सिलेक्शन
आ गया netflix.com प्राइमरी टारगेट आ गया
एंड दैट्ची
है ओके सॉरी हां तो अब आते हैं यहां पे
रिपोर्ट टेंप्लेट ये इनका अपना है खुद का
टेंप्लेट का सीन है यह कुछ भी कुछ भी नहीं
है जस्ट एक टेंप्लेट का वो है आपको चाहिए
तो आप यहां पे टेंप्लेट उठा सकते हो
टेंप्लेट बना सकते हो जनरली यहां पे आप
देखिएगा यहां टेंपलेट्स हियर पे इस पे
क्लिक कर दीजिएगा तो यहां पे आप अपना एक
टेंप्लेट बना सकते हो जो कि आप बार-बार
अलग-अलग वनबिल के लिए यूज कर सकते हो बस
सिंपल सा फंड है यही है कि उतना आपका वो
जो टाइम है वो आपका किल नहीं होगा तो अब
यहां देखो ये क्या है फैसिलिटेट यो
वर्कफ्लो एंड ऐड रिपोर्ट टेंप्लेट तो ऐड
और रिपोर्ट टेंप्लेट करेंगे तो यहां पे
अगेन टेंप्लेट का नाम दे दीजिए जो आप नाम
वहां पे सर्च करेंगे फिर बाद में जब
टेंप्लेट सर्च करेंगे तो मान लो मैं
रिपोर्ट कर रहा हूं एक्सस के लिए या क्रॉस
साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग लिख लो क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग के लिए तो मैंने उसका नाम
क्रॉस सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग दे दिया
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको देना है
डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या देना है
अवेलेबिलिटी क्या क्या है एंड इन क्लियर
स्टेप्स हाउ डू यू
रिप्रोडक्टिव
कैसे करेंगे ये आपको यहां मेंशन कर देना
है इंपैक्ट क्या है ये मेंशन कर देना है
एंड उसके बाद आपको सीवियरिंग कैलकुलेशन
मेथड जो है सीवीएसएस वाली ये ऑटोमेटिक
क्या करेगा ये इसका सीवियरिंग कैलकुलेट
करेगा अकॉर्डिंग टू जो भी आपका वो है तो
आप सीवियरिंग आप चाहो तो आप इसमें कर दो
या तो लेट्स सपोज मान लो आपको मैनुअल करना
है तो मैंने मैनुअल कर दिया अब मैनुअल में
आप सेलेक्ट कर लो भैया कि कौन स सीवियरिंग
करनी है आपको तो लो है मीडियम है हाई है
क्रिटिकल है कौन सा करना है वो आपको करना
है तो मान लो मेरे को यहां पे अ रिफ्लेक्ट
एक्सेसेस करना है मान लो यहां पे मैंने
मीडियम कर दिया कि भैया मीडियम है
दैट्ची मर्जी है प्रिविलेज रिक्वायर्ड है
क्या भैया कि नन कोई रिक्वायर्ड नहीं यूजर
इंटरेक्शन रिक्वायर्ड है नन कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है स्कोप अनचेंज्ड है
या चेंज अनचेंज्ड है ठीक है
कॉन्फिडेंशियल्टी लो रख देते हैं
इंटीग्रिटी हाई रख दे इंटीग्रिटी हाई रख
देते हैं अवेलेबिलिटी क्या है इसकी तो लो
है इस तरह से करके यहां पे लास्ट में जो
है आपको यहां पे एक स्कोर मिल जाएगा जब
आपने ये सेट किया तो यहां पे एक स्कोर
मिलता है हाई का 8.6 का एंड दैट्ची
यहां पे याद रखिएगा डिस्क्रिप्शन एंड
इंपैक्ट एंड हाउ टू रीप्रोड्यूस लिखना
होता है बस
दैट्ची की बात है कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है ये
दिस इज नॉट अ बेसिक दिस इज नॉट अ लाइक कम
कंपलसरी पार्ट ऑफ दिस रिपोर्ट राइटिंग तो
यहां पे मान लो अब सर्च करना है तो यहां
पे सर्च कर लो अब जैसे क्रॉस सेट
स्क्रिप्टिंग लिखना है आपको चलो ये री खुद
से लोड नहीं हो रहा है यानी कि हमारा
टेंप्लेट वैसे तो यहां पे आ चुका है बट
यहां पे क्या है खुद से अभी क्योंकि हमने
सेम पेज वो किया है तो इसको अगर हम रीलोड
कर देंगे पेज को तो यहां पे हमारा जो है
वो वापस से आ जाएगा जो हमने अभी टेंप्लेट
जो है इशू किया यानी बनाया था ठीक है मान
लो अभी यहां पे मैंने कर दिया netflix.com
सेलेक्ट कर लिया रिपोर्ट टेंप्लेट यहां पे
क्रॉस सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग आ गई आपकी तो
क्रॉस सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग सिलेक्ट कर ली अब
यहां पे आ रहा है वीकनेस क्या है तो मेरा
भाई क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग है अब क्रॉस
साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग में कौन है क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग क्रॉस
अ क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग में कौन सा है भैया तो मान
लो मेरा रिफ्लेक्टेड या स्टोर्ड है जो भी
करना है करो तो रिफ्लेक्टेड है मान लो तो
मैंने क्रॉस साइट जो है वो रिफ्लेक्टेड जो
है इसको सेलेक्ट कर लिया तो यहां पे जब आप
सेलेक्ट कर लोगे तो क्रॉस साइट
रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग यानी
एक्सेस रिफ्लेक्टेड का यहां पूरा का पूरा
डिस्क्रिप्शन यहां ऑटोमेटिक आ गया मतलब
इतना आसान बना दिया है ऑटोमेटिक आ गया अब
इसमें से तुम अगर जब मैनुअल बना रहे हो तो
कॉपी मार लो कि क्या होती है ये क्रॉस
साइट रिक्वेस्ट ल क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग
लेबिलिटी रिफ्लेक्टेड क्या होती है तो
रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस एक्सप्लोइट्स अकर
व्हेन एन अटैकर कॉज अ विक्टिम टू सप्लाई
डेंजरस कंटेंट टू अ वल्नरेबल वेब
एप्लीकेशन व्हिच इज देन रिफ्लेक्टेड बैक
टू द विक्टिम एंड एग्जीक्यूटेड बाय द वेब
ब्राउजर मतलब इसका एक डिस्क्रिप्शन हो गया
तो आप इसको कॉपी पास्ट मार सकते हो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है इसका यूज मैं बताता हूं
आपको कहां से आए कहां पे आएगी अब इसको
रहने देते हैं उसके बाद सीवियरिंग
सीवियरिंग क्या है सबमिट लेबिलिटी विदाउट
सीवियरिंग कोई से वेरिी आपको नहीं मेंशन
करनी है तो विदाउट कर दो मेंशन करनी है तो
यहां पे सबमिट कर दो क्योंकि आपने क्रॉस
सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग सेलेक्ट करी थी तो यहां
पे कुछ मिनिमम लाइक एक सीवीएस स्कोर
ऑटोमेटिक 3.1 आ चुकी है मैनुअल करना है तो
मैनुअल कर दो वही लो मीडियम हाई कर दो अदर
वाइज सीडीएस को 3.1 रखोगे तो फिर से ये
सारी चीजें सेट करो जो तुमने सेट करी थी
मुझे मान लो ऐसे करना है कि मैनुअल करना
है और यहां पे मान लो मीडियम रखना है
मीडियम करके छोड़ देना है बस अब आती है
मेन चीज द मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट पार्ट ऑफ योर
रिपोर्ट राइटिंग एंड यही है मेन जो हर जगह
पे आप रख आपको रखना है पर्टिकुलर वनबिल को
रिपोर्ट करते टाइम हर जगह पे आपको
पर्टिकुलर रिपोर्ट करते टाइम आपको रखनी है
क्या रखनी है मैं आपको यहां पे बताता हूं
सबसे पहले
तो यहां पर आपको रखनी
है वल्नरेबल
नेम जो वनरे बिलिटी का नेम है व आपको रखना
है
दूसरा वल्नरेबल
डिस्क्रिप्शन वनरे बिलिटी का क्या
डिस्क्रिप्शन है क्या है यह वल बिलिटी
क्या करती है य व बिलिटी यह आपको यहां पर
मेंशन करना है याद रखिएगा ध्यान दीजिएगा
अभी सभी लोग इधर ध्यान दीजिएगा गाइस
एवरीवन प्लीज लुक हेयर प्लीज प्लीज प्लीज
यहां पर आप आप लोग देखिए ठीक है लेबिलिटी
नेम आपको देना है उसके बाद लेबिलिटी की
डिस्क्रिप्शन देनी है ठीक है सभी लोग इधर
दीजिए चैट में यार बहुत लोग तुम लोग बोल
रहे हो यार सर प्लीज चैट प्लीज चैट क्यों
चैट यार इधर तो देख लो चैट चैट बोल रहे हो
क्यों चैट वनबिल डिस्क्रिप्शन दे दी यहां
पे अब यहां पे आ जाएगी वल्नरेबल
यूआरएल वल्नरेबल यूआरएल तो वल्नरेबल नेम
आपने दे दी वल्नरेबल की डिस्क्रिप्शन दे
दी अब यहां पे वलने बिलिटी का यूआरएल आपको
प्रोवाइड करना है कि भैया कौन सा जो
यूआरएल है वो आपका वल्नरेबल था तो यह आपको
प्रोवाइड कर देना है अब यहां पे चार नंबर
पे चार नंबर पे यहां पे आपको क्या
प्रोवाइड करना है वल्नरेबल
यहां पे इसको हटाओ पेलोड यूज्ड पेलोड
यूज्ड अब पेलोड यूज मान लो ऐसी वलने
बिलिटी आप फाइंड कर रहे हो कुछ ऐसी वने
बिलिटी जिसमें आप पेलोड का यूज करो जैसे
मान लो आपने एक्सएसएस फाइंड किया यू आर
यूजिंग अ पेलोड मान लो आपने एसक्यूएल आई
फाइंड किया यू आर यूजिंग अ पेलोड ठीक है
आपने एसएसआरएफ फाइंड कि यू आर यूजिंग अ
पेलोड तो आप ऐसी वलने बिलिटी फाइंड कर रहे
हो जहां पर आप किसी तरह का एक पेलोड यूज
कर रहे हो तो आप यहां पे पेलोड यूज्ड में
इस चीज को पेलोड के नाम के आगे पेलोड के
लिए आप यहां पे बताओगे कि भैया यहां पे ये
पेलोड यूज हो रहा है उसके बाद आते हैं
पांचवे नंबर पे आपने जब पेलोड लिख दिया
इधर ध्यान दे लो यार आप लोग चैट में इतना
क्यों मतलब इतना घुस क्यों जाते हो यह समझ
नहीं आ रहा है मुझे इतना क्यों घुस जाते
हो चैट में इधर ध्यान दो ना चैट में रहोगे
तो इधर कैसे इधर कैसे पढ़ पाओगे यह तो
सोचो है ना रूट कोड प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
वीडियो सर आ जाएगी भाई प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन प वीडियो आ जाएगी काहे टेंशन ले
रहे हो सब पे आएगी पहले स्टार्ट तो जो
चीजें कर रहे हो अभी शुरू से वो तो करो
यार है ना यहां पे समझ में आ रहा है सबको
पेलोड डाल दिया आपने यहां पे जो भी पेलोड
है वो डाल दिया अब यहां पे आ जाते हैं
इसका इंपैक्ट क्या होगा इस पर्टिकुलर
वनबिल का क्या इंपैक्ट होगा वो आपको बताना
है ठीक है उसके बाद आएगी स्टेप्स टू
रीप्रोड्यूस रीप्रोड्यूस दिस वनबिल
स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस दिस वलने बिलिटी
यानी कि इस वलने बिलिटी को रीप्रोड्यूस
करने का क्या स्टेप है करेक्ट क्या बोल
रहे हो भाई इस लेबिलिटी को रिपोर्ट
रीप्रोड्यूस करने का क्या आपका स्टेप है
ठीक है यह आपको यहां पे मेंशन करना है
सेवंथ में आपका जो है पीसी आपको यहां पे अ
इंक्लूड करना है यानी कि प्रूफ
ऑफ कांसेप्ट यह क्या हो सकती है या यह कोई
स्क्रीनशॉट इमेज हो सकती है यह कोई
स्क्रीनशॉट हो सकती है या यह कोई वीडियो
हो सकती है यह कोई सा भी हो सकती है ठीक
है स्क्रीनशॉट वीडियो या वही इमेज जो भी
ले लो यहां पे इमेज स्क्रीनशॉट वीडियो
इमेज जो भी होती है तो यह कुछ भी हो सकती
है तो जब आप
पीओसीओ किसी पर्टिकुलर अ बग को रिपोर्ट जब
करते हो उसमें हमेशा प्रेफरेंस दो वीडियो
को वीडियो पीसी इसको हमेशा टॉप पे रखो
क्योंकि वीडियो
पीओसीओ है तो जब वीडियो पीसी दोगे ना तो
वो बहुत अच्छा इंपैक्ट करेगा तुम्हारे
पर्टिकुलर रिपोर्ट पे जो रिपोर्ट तुम राइट
कर रहे होगे ठीक है समझ में आ गया
ओके चलिए यहां पर कुछ असामाजिक तत्व को
यहां से निकाल को निकाल के फेंकते हैं
थोड़ी देर के लिए बहुत डिस्टर्ब हो रही है
डिस्टरबेंस यार मजा नहीं आता ठीक है तो
टाइम आउट में डालते हैं 24 घंटे का कम से
कम इनको हां और कौन
है सर आई एम ऑन डे 20 शुड आई स्टार्ट
हंटिंग बग ऑन लाइव वेबसाइट एंड कंप्लीट
दिस सीरीज फर्स्ट एंड देन नहीं आप साथ में
लाइव वेबसाइट प भी हंट करो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं साथ में लाइव वेइट हंट करो ट इ टोटली
ओके ट इ टोटली ओके ठीक है टोटली ओके कोई
बात
नहीं ओके चैट को क्लोज करने का ठीक है मैं
देखता हूं अगली बार से चैट क्लोज अगर कर
दू चैट क्लोज कर दूंगा मैं अगली बार से
क्योंकि चैट में बहुत ज्यादा डिस्टरबेंस
हो रही है है
ना ठीक है
ठीक है चलिए तो यहां पे आपको समझ में आ
गया कि यहां पर आपको क्या करना है
पीओसीवी आपकी पीएससी है उसके बाद यहां पे
आठ में आपको रेडिएशन रेडिएशन बताना है
इसका या जो भी आपको अगर मान लो आपको आता
है तो लाइक या अगर आपको पता है कि भाई
इसका रेमेडी क्या होगा या इसका या या
पर्टिकुलर कोई रिकमेंडेशन है आपका तो
रिकमेंडेशन है रिकमेंडेशन है
या इसका काउंटर मेजर है काउंटर मेजर है तो
वह आप बता सकते हो अगर आपको पता है तो अगर
आपको नहीं पता तो आप इसको छोड़ भी सकते हो
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई भी दिक्कत नहीं
है ठीक है तो मेन हमारा यही एक वर्कफ्लो
होता है यही हमारा एक स्टाइल होता है
रिपोर्ट राइटिंग का इसमें हर एक चीज को
आपको बहुत बारीकी से आपको करना है और आपको
वहां पे दिखाना है तो चलिए अब इसको हम
लाइव भी करके यहां पे देखेंगे थोड़ी सी
उसके पहले हम आ जाते हैं पहले हैकर वन पे
यहां पे प्रूफ ऑफ कंसेप्ट में अब देखो
यहां पे प्रूफ ऑफ कंसेप्ट में क्या टाइटल
तो आपको क्या डालना है लेबिलिटी का टाइटल
जो भी आपका टाइटल है वो डालना अब मैं चैट
नहीं देख रहा तो आप लोग इधर ध्यान दीजिए
ठीक है लेबिलिटी का जो भी टाइटल है वह
यहां पर टाइटल आपको देना है जैसे मान लो
क्रॉस साइट मान लो मुझे य मिला है
रिफ्लेक्टेड
क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग यह मैंने यहां पर लिख दिया
उसके बाद यहां पर अब आना है भैया कि
डिस्क्रिप्शन डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या है
व्ट इज दिस वने बिलिटी इन क् स् हाउ टू य
ोड हाउ डू यू रीप्रोड्यूस इट प्लीज
रिप्लेस कल द स्क्वायर सेक्शन बिलो विद द
क्या है पर्टिनेंट डिटेल्स अब यहां
स्क्वायर सेक्शन मतलब यह पहले देते थे अभी
इनका नहीं है तो इन्होंने वो चीज आपको
जरूरत नहीं है उतना टेंशन लेने की रिमेंबर
द मोर डिटेल यू प्रोवाइड इट इज इजियर फॉर
अस टू ट्राई एंड रिस्पॉन्ड क् क्विकली सो
बी श्यर टू टेक योर टाइम फिलिंग आउट द
रिपोर्ट जितना आप डिटेल में दोगे उतना ही
इनके लिए क्या होगा भैया इतना ही इनके लिए
मजेदार होगा उतना ही इजली यह उसको
अब यहां पर क्रॉस सेट अब पहले यहां पर जब
क्रॉस सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग की बात हो रही है
तो पहले तो व्हाट इज क्रॉस सेट
स्क्रिप्टिंग पहले तो ये तो यहां पर क्या
करेंगे व्ट इज क्रॉस
साइट व्हाट
इज रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग
क्रॉस
साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग वल्नरेबल
ठीक है अब यहां पर आपको ऑलरेडी पता है कि
ये रगा रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेस क्रॉस साइड
रिफ्लेक्ट रिफर टू ये चीज करके द मोस्ट
कॉमन मेकेम फॉर डिलीवरी कं आल्सो इंक्लूड
पैरामीटर यहां पे करके ऐसे करके यहां पे
ऐसे करके यहां से कॉपी कर लिया कॉपी किया
एंड यहां पे हालांकि इनको ऑलरेडी पता होता
है ये चीज तो इतना बड़ा लिखने की जरूरत है
नहीं तो यहां पे एक छोटा सा जो इसका
डिस्क्रिप्शन है भैया वो छोटा सा
डिस्क्रिप्शन यहां पे उठाया और यहां पे
चुपचाप इसका बता दिया कि व्हाट इज
रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग ठीक
है बस तो रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस अकर व्हेन ये
चीज करके उसके बाद उसके बाद क्या करना है
यहां पे लेबिलिटी
डिस्क्रिप्शन ठीक है लेबिलिटी नेम एंड
उसके बाद डिस्क्रिप्शन यहां पे नेम दे
दिया आपने अब यहां पे व्हाट इज यहां पे
हमें क्या देना था पहले देखिए यहां पे
लेबिलिटी का नाम हमने दे दिया अब लेबिलिटी
का डिस्क्रिप्शन देना है तो डिस्क्रिप्शन
में हमें यही हो गया व्हाट इज जो
रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस हैट स्क्रिप्टिंग है ये
पूरा का पूरा एक डिस्क्रिप्शन ही हो गया
तो आप इसमें जितना ना ऐड करना चाहे कर
दीजिए हालांकि ये जो है आराम से आपको
google2 स्क्रिप्टिंग इज अटैक वेर
मालीशियस यहां से ये चीज किया एंड यहां से
यहां पे कॉपी कर लिया एंड यहां पे आपने
इसको पेस्ट कर दिया बस दैट्ची यह कहानी हो
गई समाप्त यह कहानी हो गई हमारी पूरी तो
यहां पे व्हाट इज द अवेलेबिलिटी आ गया
भैया इन क्लियर स्टेप्स हाउ डू यू
रीप्रोड्यूस इट यह भी आपको यहां पे बताना
है उसके बाद यहां इंपैक्ट वाली फील्ड है
देखो यहां पे इंपैक्ट वाली फील्ड यहां है
तो आपको जो इंपैक्ट वाली फील्ड है यहां तक
यह वाली इसको यहां पे छोड़ देना है एंड
बाकी चीजें आपको यहां पे मेंशन कर देनी है
तो अब मुझे यहां पे क्या मेंशन करना है
वल्नरेबल यूआरएल वल्नरेबल
यूआरएल अब वल्नरेबल यूआरएल में आप यहां पे
डाल दीजिए जो भी यूआरएल है मान लो मेरा
यूआरएल है netflix.com
एडमिन स्
अ कसोल स् यूजर क्वेश्च मार्क आईडी = 1
मान लो कुछ इस तरह का एक लोकेशन है जहां
पे यह वल्नरेबल है इस पर्टिकुलर आईडी
पैरामीटर के लिए ठीक है तो यहां पे हमने
यह पूरा का पूरा यहां पे डाल दिया
वल्नरेबल यूज यूआरएल में अब यहां पे डालना
है पेलोड यूज्ड पेलोड यूज्ड अब मान लो
मैंने यहां पे क्या क्रॉसड स्क्रिप्टिंग
खोज है तो मैंने पेलोड यूज किया है
स्क्रिप्ट
अलर्ट
अ डॉक्यूमेंट ड कुकी एंड यहां पे
स्क्रिप्ट क्लोज कर दिया तो ये हमने यहां
पे पेलोड मेंशन कर दिया तो यूआरएल हो गया
हमारा ठीक है ये डन हो गया लेबिलिटी नेम
हो गया डिस्क्रिप्शन हो गया यूआरएल हो गया
पेरिड हमने बता दिया ये सब कुछ हमने यहां
पे कर दिया अब यहां पे बारी आती है
स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस दिस पर्टिकुलर
वनबिल कि इस वनबिल को रीप्रोड्यूस कैसे हम
कर सकते हैं तो अब यहां पर आपको लिखना है
स्टेप्स टू
रीप्रोड्यूस
दिस आर एक्सेसेस
वलने बिलिटी मतलब रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस
वलने बिलिटी तो स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस
दिस एक्सेस वल बिलिटी अब यहां पर आपको एक
नंबर देना है कि गो टू द गिवन यूआरएल मतलब
जो यूआरएल है गो टू दिस
यूआरएल गो टू दिस यूआरएल यूआरएल यहां पर
दे दीजिए ठीक है एक्सस के केस में यहां पर
बात कर रहे हैं उसके बाद यहां
पर कैप्चर द रिक्वेस्ट इन बॉब सूट थर्ड
में सेंड दिस रिक्वेस्ट टू
रिपीटर रिपीटर को रिक्वेस्ट भेजिए चार में
ऐड पेलोड ठीक है यहां पर रिपीटर को आपने
भेज दिया अब यहां प ऐड पेलो टू द पैरामीटर
आईडी ऐड एक्सेस पेलोड ड दिस एक्सेसेस
पेलोड टू द पैरामीटर आईडी एंड यहां पर
आपने यहां पर आपने पेलोड इ इक्वल टू एंड
यहां पर आपने मेंशन जो किया था ओबवियसली
वही वाली पेलोड है जो पेलोड आपने यहां पर
एंटर करना है तो मैंने य प एंटर कर दिया
उसके बाद यहां पर पांच में क्या है कॉपी
दिस सेंड दिस रिक्वेस्ट एंड सेंड दिस
रिक्वेस्ट एंड नोटिस
नोटिस द रिजल्ट इन
रिस्पांस ठीक है कॉपी द
रिस्पांस एंड ओपन इन
अ
ब्राउजर एंड
बूम एक्सेसेस विल
रिफ्लेक्ट सिंपल एक्सेस रिफ्लेक्ट एक्सेस
इ
देर देयर बस तो इस तरीक से आपने क्या किया
एक रीप्रोड्यूस का पूरा का पूरा एक स्टेप
बना दिया कि भैया इस ल पे जा यह मैंने एक
शॉर्ट में लिखा है यह मैं आपके आईडिया के
लिए लिखा है मैंने आपको कि इस यूआरएल पे
जाइए यहां पे कैप्चर कीजिए एक-एक स्टेप जो
आपको उस पर्टिकुलर वनबिल को
रिप्रोडक्शन कर देना है तो यह आपने
स्टेप्स ट रीप्रोड्यूस कर दिया अब यहां पे
आती है प्रूफ ऑफ़ कंसेप्ट की बारी एंड
इंपैक्ट की बारी ठीक है हमने तो यहां पे
यह चीज़ स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस वाला काम
खत्म कर लिया इसमें अब कुछ नहीं करना
इंपैक्ट अब यहां पे व्हाट सिक्योरिटी
इंपैक्ट कैन एन अटैकर अचीव मतलब अब क्या
इंपैक्ट हो सकता है तो य अगेन सेम
रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग
इंपैक्ट ग एंड इसमें आप चर जीपीटी का यूज
कर सकते हैं च जीपीटी इज वेरी वेरी
इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग तो यहां पे आप देख सकते
हो रिफ्लेक्ट यह तो छोड़ो द रियल इंपैक्ट
ऑफ क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग मान
लो ठीक है कोई वेबसाइट है यहां
पे यहां प तो अब आपको इंपैक्ट में क्या
लिखना है यहां पर देखो इंपैक्ट में इस
तरीके से अकाउंट हाईजैकिंग तो यहां पे ऐसे
मेंशन करना है
आपको
द इंपैक्ट ऑफ आर एक्सेसेस कैन बी यहां प
अब यहां पे आपको लिख देना है जैसे क्या
लिखना है भैया अकाउंट हाईजैकिंग हो सकती
है ठीक है यहां से अकाउंट हाईजैकिंग हो
सकती है दूसरा क्या हो सकता है भैया
आपका क्रेडेंशियल स्टीलिंग हो सकती है ठीक
है तीसरा क्या हो सकता है भै आपका
सेंसिटिव डाटा यहां पे एक्सपोजर हो सकता
है तो यहां पे सेंसिटिव डाटा एक्सपोजर लिख
दिया यहां पे उसके बाद ड्राइव बाय
डाउनलोड्स हो सकता है तो ड्राइव बाय
डाउनलोडस हमने कर दिया उसके बाद अदर
अटैक्स जिसमें कि अलग-अलग तरह के अटैक्स
यहां पे आ रहे हैं तो वो सारी चीजें यहां
पे मेंशन है अब इसमें आप चाहो तो इसको
एक्सप्लेन भी कर सकते हो आप एक-एक पॉइंट
को एक्सप्लेन कर सकते हो अगर आपको इतना
करना है तो अदर वाइज आप इसको इतना ही करके
छोड़ सकते हो क्योंकि क्या है ना पीछे जो
ट्रैक टीम बैठी है जो रिसर्चस की
सिक्योरिटी टीम बैठी हुई है उस प्रोग्राम
के लिए उन को भी पता है उनको भी नॉलेज है
उस चीज की हां कोई बहुत ही सीवियर
वल्नरेबल कोई ऐसी वल्नरेबल कोई ऐसा बग जो
है जो अब तक शायद सिक्योरिटी टीम ने भी
नहीं देखा हो या उनको भी नहीं पता हो या
उनको भी रीप्रोड्यूस करने में दिक्कत आ
सकती हो उसमें आपको बहुत ही एक-एक बारीकी
से सब कुछ लिखना होगा क्योंकि आपको ये
कंसीडर फिर करना है कि सामने वाले रिसर्चर
टीम को हो सकता है ये चीज ना पता हो ये तो
कॉमन चीजें है एक्सएसएस सीएसआरएफ एसएसआरएफ
आपका एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन ये सब कॉमन
अवेलेबिलिटीज है कुछ ऐसे वने एबिलिटीज आती
हैं जो जनरली जो होती है वो बहुत लेस कॉमन
होती है एंड कई बार रिसर्चस टीम को सॉरी
सिक्योरिटी टीम जो कंपनी की होती है
प्रोग्राम की होती है उनको दिक्कत आती है
उसको
रिप्रोडक्टिव जब आप लिखेंगे तो आप उसको और
ज्यादा डिटेल में ऐसा लिखेंगे जैसे आप
उसको पढ़ा रहे हैं आप सामने वाली
सिक्योरिटी टीम को सिखा रहे हैं कि देखो
सीखो ऐसे करोगे तो ऐसे होगा ऐसे करोगे तो
ऐसे होगा तुम्हें कुछ नहीं पता है मैं
आपको बताता हूं मैं तुम्हें सब कुछ
गाइडलाइन करता हूं बताता हूं एंड वैसे तुम
करो तो ये आपको करना पड़ेगा फिलहाल इसके
लिए इतना काफी हो गया आपका कि भैया ये
इसका इंपैक्ट है अब यहां पे यहां दिया हुआ
है इन्होंने ड्रैग एंड ड्रॉप सेलेक्ट
फाइल्स तो यहां पे आपको फाइल्स ड्रैग एंड
ड्रॉप करने का एक ऑप्शन दिया है तो ये एक
अच्छी बात है आप क्लिक करेंगे आपके पास
कोई स्क्रीनशॉट है कुछ आपका वीडियो है कुछ
ऐसा है तो आप यहां पे ये डाल सकते हैं अब
मान लो यहां पे क्या है कि 250 एब पर फाइल
का यहां पे रिस्ट्रिक्शन लगा रखा है अब
मान लो लेट्स सपोज कि भैया हमें 250 एब से
ज्यादा की फाइल है या ज्यादा हमारे को
अपलोड करना है क्या करना ये सब चीजें हैं
आपकी ठीक है जब ऐसी चीजें हो तो आप इसको
सिंपल इस डिस्क्रिप्शन वाले में भी यहां
पे दे सकते हो यहां पे यहां पे पीओ वीडियो
लिंक करके यहां लिंक डाल के आप इनको दे
सकते हो कोई भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं आएगी कोई भी
इशू नहीं आएगी ठीक है बस क्योंकि यहां पे
इनका साइज इश्यूज मान लो साइज इशू मेरे को
एक ही वीडियो में देना है कौन इतना टेंशन
ले तो कर दो छोटी-मोटी स्क्रीनशॉट्स वगैरह
हैं तो आप यहां से करके यहां से अपलोड कर
सकते हो या वैसे है तो वीडियो लिंक को
कहीं पे वीडियो को इमेजेस को फोटो को
कोई भी ऐसी सिंपल अपलोड सर्विस पे यूज़
करना अपलोड करो और यहां पे लिंक डाल दो अब
कई बार
राइट क्लिक करके मैनेज एक्सेस पे जाओ या
शेयर पे जाओ और वहां पे नीचे में एक
एक्सेस का होता है कि एनी वन विद दिस लिंक
कैन व्यू तो व्यू वाला सेलेक्ट करो
रिस्ट्रिक्टर है वो व्यू करो और डन करो तब
कॉपी करके यहां लिंक डाला करो तो यहां पे
लिंक डालो एंड यहां पे वीडियो प जो पीओ
उसकी लिंक आ जाएगी यहां पे सारे जो
इंपैक्ट आपने दिखाए वो इंपैक्ट आ गया अब
इसके साथ-साथ एक चीज यहां पे क्या है
पीओसीआर प्रोड्यूस दिस वनबिल आ गया अब आता
है रेमेडी रिकमेंडेशन या काउंटर मेजर अगर
मान लो आपको पता है कि इसका काउंटर मेजर
क्या है आपको पता है अगर तो आप काउंटर
मेजर वाला पार्ट या रेमेडी वाला पार्ट लिख
के उसकी डिटेल बता सकते हो जो डेवलपर टीम
को शायद इजी कर दे इजी बना दे उनके लिए
एंड उनको आईडिया लग जाए कि अच्छा अच्छा
ऐसे करना है अगर उनको नहीं नोन है तो उनको
पता नहीं है तो ठीक है दैट्ची म को सिर्फ
इतना मतलब होता है आपके इस पार्ट से
स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस से या अगर आपने
कोई पीओसीओ लिंक ली है उससे क्योंकि उनको
ऊपर में अपने जो हायर जो उनकी अथॉरिटी
होती है जो ऊपर की टीम उनके साथ काम कर
रही होती है कोऑर्डिनेट कर रही होती है
हायर अथॉरिटी नहीं बोलूंगा मैं ऊपर वाली
टीम जो कोऑर्डिनेट कर रही होती है उस
पर्टिकुलर ट्रैक टीम से या रिसर्च उस
पर्टिकुलर सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर से उनको
रिप्रोडक्टिव उतना आपका इजली जो है
स्विफ्टली जो है आपके रिपोर्ट पर काम होगा
एंड आपको एप्रिसिएशन मिलेगी जब आप बहुत
डिटेल रिपोर्ट बना के किसी को देते हैं यह
ठीक है यह सबको पहले यह बताइए मुझे इतना
समझने में कोई दिक्कत आया इस पर्टिकुलर
टॉपिक के लिए तो मुझे बताइए फिलहाल इतना
समझने में कोई दिक्कत आ
बताइए चैट नहीं पड़ता भाई चैट नहीं पड़ता
मैं मैं अभी पढ़ाने में बिजी हूं पढ़ाने
पर ध्यान दूंगा चैट पर ध्यान थोड़ी ना
दूंगा इधर देख लो
समझने में कोई दिक्कत है भाई सब सब समझ
में आ
गया बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए जल्दी बताइए
जल्दी बताइए जल्दी सभी लोग रिप्लाई सभी
लोग रिप्लाई करेंगे सी लोग एवरी बडी
ओके ओके ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है
बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया
बढ़िया टाटा
डन
डन अ फ्यू स्कैमर्स आर हियर हु इज
इरिटेटिंग हां पता है मुझे स्कैमर्स लोग आ
जाते हैं बेचारे क्या कर सकते हैं जाने दो
जो बार-बार एक ही चीज को बार-बार चैट में
लिखेंगे उनको टाइम आउट कर दिया जाएगा और
उनको बैन कर दिया जाएगा तो प्लीज मत लिखिए
क्योंकि मैं फिर वैसे मैसेज को पढ़ता भी
नहीं हूं मैं लेता भी नहीं हूं ठीक है
यहां पे मैं सिखाने आया हूं यहां पे ये
स्पैम को इंटरटेन करने नहीं आया हूं ठीक
है तो जिनको सीखना है उनके टाइम की वैल्यू
मैं करता हूं और उनके टाइम की वैल्यू आपको
भी करनी चाहिए ठीक है बाकी लोगों से कोई
मतलब नहीं है जो सीखना है बस उनसे मतलब
है काउंटर मेजर मतलब यार कि कैसे ठीक कर
सकते हैं काउंटर मेजर का मतलब होता है कि
आप इसको आप मुझे स्टेप्स बताइए स्टेप्स टू
स्टेप्स टू
मिटिगेट मिटिगेट दिस वल्नरेबल
मिटिगेट दिस वल्नरेबल समझ में आया कि अगर
आपको पता है तो अगर नहीं पता तो भैया तो
इसको छोड़ दो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तुम्हारे
लिए कोई टेंशन अब जब तुम सब ये सब चीजें
कर लोगे मेंशन कर दोगे लिख दोगे तो यहां
पे एक रिव्यू एंड सबमिट योर रिपोर्ट आएगी
ये देखो रिव्यू एंड सबमिट योर रिपोर्ट और
यही आपका जो रिव्यू है यही आपका एक
फॉर्मेट बन जाएगा रिपोर्ट राइटिंग का यानी
कि अगर मान लो कोई ऐसा रिपोर्ट राइटिंग आप
कर रहे हो मान लो मान लो जैसे कि मैं करता
हूं
अ यहां पे करते हैं इनटाइटल
अ इनटाइटल कर दिया
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर सिंपल सा करते हैं
अब यहां से मैंने कोई एक रिपोर्ट के लिए
निकाला कक मान लो यहां पे कक नाम की
वेबसाइट है रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर
प्रोग्राम है ठीक है अब इन्होंने क्या
किया है सेंड द वनबिल रिपोर्ट टू वनबिल
रिपोर्ट @ kayak.com अब मुझे मान लो इनको
कोई रिपोर्ट बना के भेजेंगे इनको तो इनके
लिए अलग से फॉर्मेट तो है नहीं जैसे
हैकरों ने प्रोवाइड किया है मुझे एक प्री
बिल्ट फॉर्मेट उस तरह का तो कुछ है नहीं
है ना तो मैं इनको कैसे भेजूंगा भैया तो
इनको मैं हैकर वन से कॉपी मारूंगा ना यार
हैकर वन से चोरी कर लूंगा उधर से उठा
लूंगा इधर डाल दूंगा एकदम मस्त एकदम
प्रोफेशनल रिपोर्ट लगेगा एकदम शानदार
रिपोर्ट लगेगा बस ईमेल कॉपी किया g
mail2 वाले में एंड वहां पे बॉडी में अब
यहां पे रिपोर्ट लिखना शुरू कर दिया अब
इसको रिपोर्ट कैसे लिखेंगे सेम वही
रिपोर्ट यहां पे कर देंगे मान लो कक कया
कक को लिखना है ना कया कक कक को लिखना है
मुझे इसको तो कक को लिखना है तो मुझे क्या
करना है ये जो रिव्यू वाली पार्ट है इसको
पूरा का पूरा ऐसे करके कहीं कुछ नहीं करना
है यहां से सीधा करके कॉपी मारने का यहां
गए और यहां पेस्ट मारने का
दैट्ची तो डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या है
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आ जाओ व्हाट इज
रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग तो
इसका डिटेल आ गया यहां पे क्या है
वल्नरेबल यूआरएल क्या है तो यह है ठीक है
भैया पेलोड यूज तो यह है स्टेप्स टू
रीप्रोड्यूस भी है क्या हां तो ये है ना
तो ये तो पूरा का पूरा स्टेप्स
रीप्रोड्यूस है यहां पे उसके बाद पीओसीओ
लिंक है कोई हां तो यहां पे है कोई काउंटर
मेजर भी है या स्टेप्स टू मिटिगेट तो हां
है उसके बाद कोई इ सॉरी कोई इंपैक्ट है तो
हां जी यहां पे है इंपैक्ट है अब मुझे
बताओ यह पूरा का पूरा ऑटोमेटिक तैयार हो
गया कि नहीं हो गया यह पूरा का पूरा
ऑटोमेटिक तुम्हारा तैयार हो गया एक
रिपोर्ट का फॉर्मेट जिसके लिए इतना परेशान
रहते हो तैयार हो गया यह बताइए
मुझे हां बिल्कुल चर जीपीटी से चर जीपीटी
की हेल्प ले सकते हो च जीपीटी इ वेरी
वंडरफुल थिंग इन सच सिनेरियो तो उसकी
हेल्प ले सकते हो लेकिन चर जीपीटी को पूरा
कॉपी पेस्ट मत मारना थोड़ा वहां भी देखना
कई बार चर जीपीटी से गलतियां होती है इधर
उधर कर देता है देखना खुद से उसमें
एडिटिंग करना खुद से कुछ मैनुअल चेंजेज
करना परफेक्ट जब हो जाए तो उसको यूज कर
लेना
तो तैयार हो गया ये आपका रिपोर्ट का
पूरा कैन यू रिपीट
रिप्रोडक्टिव
का मतलब क्या होता है यहां पे स्टेप्स टू
रीप्रोड्यूस दिस एक्सेस वल बिलिटी इसका
मतलब सिंपल सा है कि आपने कौन-कौन से
स्टेप्स यूज किए हैं ताकि एक्सेसेस आपको
यह मिल गया मान लो चलो अब मान लो मेरे पास
एक है एक यूआरएल है टे ph.com यहां पे मैं
चलता हूं यहां पे मैं
स्क्रिप्ट
अलर्ट वन
स्क्रिप्ट क्लोज अब यहां मैंने एंटर किया
एक्सेस आ गया ठीक है य एक्सेस मुझे मिल गई
अच्छी बात है अब यहां पर मैंने क्या किया
इसका स्क्रीनशॉट ले लिया क्या किया मैंने
इसका स्क्रीनशॉट ले लिया स्क्रीनशॉट कैसे
लेते हैं
भैया प्रिंट स्क्रीन दबाओ प्रिंट स्क्रीन
दबाओ इस तरीके से आ गया और मैंने इसको
यहां
पर इसको वैसे पूरा ही लेना पड़ेगा तुम्हें
तो प्रिंट स्क्रीन लिया यहां पे अब यहां
से ऊपर यूआरएल के साथ ही तुम्हें यहां से
इस तरीके से करके यहां पे स्क्रीनशॉट ले
लिया अब यहां प स्क्रीनशॉट आ गई यहां पे
कॉपी टू क्लिप बोर्ड क्लिप बोर्ड में कॉपी
हो गई है क्लिक हियर टू मार्क अप एंड शेयर
तो मान लो मेरे पास ये स्क्रीनशॉट आ गई
यहां पे और इसको मैंने यहां पर सेव कर
दिया मैं यहां प क्या कर देता हूं इसको
पर्टिकुलर पे सेव एस कर देता हूं एंड यहां
कर देता हूं मैं डेस्कटॉप पे डेस्कटॉप पे
आ गए ए यहां कर देता हूं एक्सेसेस
एक्सस
रिपोर्ट या एक्सस पीओ नाम से सेव कर देता
हूं ठीक है ये तो आ गई अब अब यहां पे मुझे
जो भी जो मुझे यहां पे चीजें लगी है वह
मैंने यहां पर चीजें की है तो अब मैं यहां
पर क्या करूंगा स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस
में क्या करूंगा गो टू दिस यूआरएल यूआरएल
क्या है भैया हमारा यह यूआरएल
है यह हमारा क्या है यूआरएल है ठीक है
टेस्ट इज इक्वल टू कैप्चर द रिक्वेस्ट इन
बॉब शूट ठीक है अगर आपने बॉब शूट में जैसे
अगर आपने बॉब शूट में करी है तो यहां पे
बॉब शूट यहां पे लिखोगे सिंपल सा कि यहां
भैया मैंने बब शूट में करिए यज करिए इसको
हम
रिप्रोडक्टिव
टू द पैरामीटर पेलोड इ इक्वल टू ये वाली
चीज है तो भैया मुझे ये वाली जो एक्सेसेस
है उसको पैरामीटर में डाला यहां पे करके
और यहां पे कॉपी द रेस्प ओपन इन ब्राउजर
एंड बम हमारा जैसे ही ओपन हुआ ब्राउजर में
हमारे को एक्सेसेस जो है यहां पे मिल चुकी
है ट्स इट बस आपको इतना ही काम करना है हो
गया आपका यह पूरा का पूरा स्टेप्स टू रि
प्रोड्यूस मतलब आपने जो जो स्टेप लिए हैं
उस लेबिलिटी को फाइंड करने में
रिप्रोडक्टिव
किया वो किया यहां भी लिख दिया खत्म कहानी
समझ में आ गया बस ट्स इट ओके रूट खाली मैं
दे दूंगा
वहां पर बता दूंगा
आपको सर लास्ट टाइम यू बैन मी विदाउट रीजन
मैं विदाउट रीजन किसी को बैन नहीं करता
अगर आपको बैन किया है तो उसके पीछे रीजन
होगा कुछ ना कुछ विदाउट रीजन आई नेवर बैन
एनी वन ठीक
है आई हैव गट अ प्राइस टेंपर्ड साइट एंड
वेयर आई कैन मैनिपुलेट द प्राइस शुड आई
डायरेक्टली रिपोर्ट देम डू दे रिवर्ड मी
अगर उनका बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम है तो
रिपोर्ट करे रिपोर्ट करो रिवर्ड कर सकते
हैं वो लेकिन अगर नहीं है तो उस प्रोग्राम
के ऊपर डिपेंड करता है कि वो आपको रिपोर्ट
आपके रिपोर्ट को किस तरह से ले क्योंकि
उनका ना कोई वीडीपी वनबिल डिस्क्लोजर
प्रोग्राम अगर नहीं है कोई या कोई
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर प्रोग्राम नहीं है
या कोई बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम नहीं है कुछ भी
नहीं है तो वो कंपनी डिसाइड करेगी कि आपको
रिवॉर्ड देना है कि नहीं देना है कि
इग्नोर मार देना है कि आपको बिना बताए ही
उसको ठीक कर लेना है उस वल बिलिटी को दैट
इज टोटली अपऑन कंपनी तो आप चाहे तो
रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं मे बी ठीक है कले के
टूल्स प ठीक है दिस वाज माय फर्स्ट टाइम
आई एम वाचिंग यू लाइव आफ्टर कंपलीटिंग 40
वीडियोस टुडे माय हैप्पीनेस लेवल लव यू सर
जी प्रणव कुस्वाहा क्या बात है प्रणव 40
वीडियो के बाद प्रणव हमारे बीच हैं फर्स्ट
लाइव में एंड दिस इज अमेजिंग ये मुझे काफी
अच्छा
काफी काफी ज्यादा मुझे मजा आता है ऐसी
चीजें जब चैट में आती है तो कोई 40 वीडियो
देख के और अभी लाइव में आ चुका यह
डेडिकेशन एंड यह जो कंसिस्टेंसी है ना
आपके अंदर भी होनी चाहिए तो इसलिए
कंसिस्टेंसी डेडिकेशन एंड हार्ड वर्क ठीक
है साथ में ऑनेस्टी होनी चाहिए तो फिर आप
कहीं पे भी जा सकते हो किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
मुकाम पे पहुंच सकते हो किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
एक डेस्टिनी तक जा सकते हो जो आपको चाहिए
जो आपको चाहिए वो आपको मिलेगा ठीक है इतना
हम समझिए बस विश्वास रखिए उस ऊपर वाले में
विश्वास रखिए ट्रस्ट रखिए एंड इतना मानिए
कि जो भी चीजें हो रही हैं वो आपके भले के
लिए और अच्छे के लिए हो रही हैं एंड उसमें
पॉजिटिव एनर्जी है एंड आपको वो एक अलग
हाइट प लेकर जाएंगी आप उस पर्टिकुलर हाइट
को अचीव करोगे जो आप अचीव करना चाहते हो
आप किसी भी बैकग्राउंड से किसी भी जगह से
बिलोंग करते हो किसी भी पर्टिकुलर किसी भी
जगह से बिलंग करते हो डजन मैटर टियर थ्री
सिटी से छोटी सिटी से बिलोंग करते हो उससे
भी कोई मैटर नहीं करता छोटे-छोटे सिटीज से
ही लोग पता नहीं कितने बड़े-बड़े लोग बन
चुके हैं आज के टाइम में जिनके पास पैसा
है फेम है पावर है हर एक चीज है एंड वो आप
भी कर सकते हैं यही लाइफ है एंड लाइफ में
हर किसी को जनरली मोस्टली यही चीज चाहिए
होती है एंड वो आपके हाथों में होता है तो
ट्रस्ट ऑन द प्रोसेस ट्रस्ट ऑन द गॉड एंड
एवरीथिंग विल बी योर्स जस्ट कीप डूइंग
थिंग्स दैट यू लव दैट यू हैव पैशन फॉर एंड
जस्ट जस्ट डोंट एवर एवर गेट टायर्ड ऑफ इट
एंड एवरीथिंग यू डू डू विथ हाई
कंसिस्टेंसी हार्ड वर्क एंड डेडिकेशन विथ
ऑनेस्टी धन्यवाद ठीक है समझ में आ रहा ओके
समझ में आया अभी का अभी का आपको गीता का
ज्ञान कैसा लगा ज्ञान कैसा लगा आपको बताइए
अभी जो ज्ञान आपको मिला अभी आई हैव द पैशन
नेक्स्ट लेवल बहुत बढ़िया है पैशन के साथ
कीजिए सब कुछ होगा
28 लेक्चर कंप्लीट क्या बात है भाई 28
लेक्चर 28 लेक्चर कंप्लीट करना इज आल्सो
वेरी गुड
अचीवमेंट ठीक है ना भाई मुझे नितेश ही बन
के रहना है नितीश नहीं भाई
नितेश ठीक
है
चलिए ओके तो यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
कि इस तरीके से आपका जो बग बाउंट रिपोर्ट
है वो तैयार हो जाएगा अब मैं आपको एक चीज
और बता देता हूं हर प्लेटफॉर्म का डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट सिनेरियो डिफरेंट डिफरेंट होते
हैं आपके रिपोर्ट राइटिंग का रिपोर्ट का
प्रेजेंट करने का रिपोर्ट राइटिंग को तो
आप यहां से कॉपी पेस्ट मारना एकदम मस्त
एकदम आपका काम हो जाएगा काम चल जाएगा यहां
पे प्रूफ ऑफ कांसेप्ट में जो चीजें लिखोगे
आप यहां से कॉपी पेस्ट मार के पूरा का
पूरा रिपोर्ट तैयार कर सकते हो ये मैं
आपको एक तरीका बता दिया याद रखो वही बात
वही काम होता है टीचर का काम होता है आपको
गाइड करना ऐसा गाइड करना कि आप अपने
रास्ते खुद बना सको आपको रास्ता बना के
देना टीचर का कभी काम नहीं होता होना भी
नहीं चाहिए ठीक है फिर आप क्या करोगे आपको
क्या है है आपको मान लो ना आपको पता नहीं
है कुछ आपको घर बनाना है टीचर क्या करेगा
आपको ईंट लाके दे देगा आपको क्या लगा छड़
लाके दे देगा जो सरिया होता है वो लाके दे
देगा आपको आपको और क्या लाएगा जो भी
सीमेंट होता है बालू होती है वह सारी
चीजें लाके आपके सामने रख देगा जो भी
चीजें चाहिए लकड़ी वगैरह और आपको अब उसका
यूज करना है कब कहां क्या यूज करना है
कितने प्रोपोर्शन में करना है वो आपको
सीखना है वही चीज आपको सिखा के आपको दे
देगा एंड आप अपना घर बनाते रहिए अब आप
उसको उस घर को दो मंजिल बनाना है तीन
मंजिल बनाना है 10 मंजिल बनाना है उस घर
के अंदर डेकोरेशन इंटीरियर कैसा करना वो
सब आपका काम है वो आपके अपने स्किल और
आपके अपने टैलेंट पे होगा तो वोह आपको खुद
डेवलप करना है एक्सप्लोर करना है
एक्सप्लोर करने की क्षमता आपके अंदर जब तक
नहीं आएगी तब तक आप पीछे रुके रहेंगे जैसे
ही आ गई तैसे ही आप आगे बढ़ गए दैट्ची
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल कोई बात नहीं रूट काली
यहां पे आप आइए यहां पे आपको खतरनाक वाली
नॉलेज मिल जाएगी टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है
ठीक है आप पूरी सीरीज को भी कंप्लीट कीजिए
अभी भी देखिए तो अब आते हैं यहां पे यह तो
हमने हैकर वन का देखा अब आते हैं बक
क्राउड पे बक क्राउड का थोड़ा सा डिफरेंट
है इनका अपना एक अ टैक्सो है जिसको
बेसिकली यह जिसके बेसिस पे ये डिसाइड करते
हैं कि आपकी जो वनबिल है वो किस कैटेगरी
में है p1 p2 p3 इनका अपना है अलग है तो
हम कोई सा भी एक प्रोग्राम उठा लेते हैं
मान
लो कोई भी प्रोग्राम ले लो बुलिस एक्सचेंज
ले लो मोला ये ले लो हार्डवेयर इंगेजमेंट
या जो भी है अब यहां पे ले लिया अब यहां
पे जब तुम आ जाओगे तो यहां पे सारी
डिटेल्स फिर से पढ़ना है तुम्हें स्कोप
एंड रिवर्ड अगेन इसकी पूरी डिटेल यहां पे
प्रोग्राम की जो डिटेल है वो पढ़िए यहां
पे ठीक है उसके बाद स्कोप एंड रिवार्ड्स
पढ़िए यहां पे ठीक है यहां सारी डिटेल सी
वेरि ब्रेकडाउन जो है इनका पीव कैटेगरी
में क्या-क्या किस तरीके से चीजें आती हैं
क्या काम होता है किस तरीके से सारी चीजें
पढ़ लीजिएगा फोकस एरिया अगेन फिर से आप
पढ़ लीजिएगा आउट ऑफ़ स्कोप पढ़ लीजिएगा
रिपोर्ट का फॉर्मेट जो है इन्होंने देखो
इन्होंने भी रिपोर्ट का फॉर्मेट बता दिया
है कितना इजी है कहां कुछ टेंशन लेना है
और डिस्क्रिप्टिव टाइटल देना है स्टेप बाय
स्टेप गाइड ऑफ रिप्लिकेटिंग द लेबिलिटी और
डेमोंस्ट्रेटिव प्रूफ ऑफ़ कंसेप्ट दे देना
है प्रेसा इज एंड डिटेल अकाउंट ऑफ द इशू
इंक्लूडिंग द डिवाइस नेम एंड वर्जन दे
देना है अ लिस्ट ऑफ कंपोनेंट अफेक्टेड कौन
सा कंपोनेंट अफेक्टेड है और थ्रू रूट थोरो
रूट कॉज एनालाइजिंग एक्सप्लेन व्हाई दिस
इशू इज हैपनिंग यह कर देना है खत्म उसके
बाद यह सारी डिटेल पढ़ लीजिएगा अब जब
इसमें आप रिपोर्ट करने जाइएगा सबमिट
रिपोर्ट प क्लिक कीजिएगा तो यहां पे आपको
टाइटल देना है कि कौन सा भैया तो वही है
रिफ्लेक्टेड
क्रॉस
साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग अब टारगेट कौन सा है भैया तो
अब टारगेट आपको चूज कीजिए कि ऑल मोटरोला
डिवाइस रनिंग 13 या अदर या जो भी टारगेट
है तो मान लो मैं अदर करता हूं तो यहां पे
कर दिया अब यहां पे इनका एक वी आरटी
कैटेगरी आता है इनका क्या आता है वी आरटी
कैटेगरी इनका थोड़ा सा डिफरेंट है यहां पे
इन्होंने एक अपना एक टैक्सो बना रखा है
जिसको बोलते हैं ब क्राउड्स वनबिल रेटिंग
टैक्सो क्या है ये ये जो है वी आरटी इज अ
रिसोर्स आउटलाइनिंग बक क्राउट्स बेसलाइन
प्रायोरिटी रेटिंग्स इंक्लूडिंग सर्टेन एज
केसेस फॉर कॉमन लेबिलिटी हैव अ सजेशन यहां
पे आ जाइए अब इनका आप देख सकते हैं वी
आरटी तो किस तरीके से इन्होंने फॉर्म किया
है ये आप देख लीजिए जैसे p1 कैटेगरी में
क्या डाला है सर्वर सिक्योरिटी मिस
कॉन्फिन यूजिंग डिफॉल्ट क्रेडेंशियल इसका
स्पे सिफिक अगर नेम दिया जाए देखा जाए तो
यह है यानी कि अगर आपको कोई सर्वर
सिक्योरिटी मिस कन्फेशन मिलती है यानी कि
डिफॉल्ट कंसल्स लॉगइन कहीं पे मिलता है वो
p1 कैटेगरी में आती है और उसको आपकी मस्त
बाउंट मिलेगी सर्वर साइड इंजेक्शन यहां पे
है तो उसका उसमें फाइल इंक्लूजन यहां पे
और उसमें कौन सा एलएफआई ठीक है लोकल वाली
इसको भी p1 कैटेगरी में डाला है आरसी p1
में है एसक्यूएल p1 में है एक्सएक्सई p1
में है यहां पे आपका ऑथेंटिकेशन बायपास p1
में यहां पे डिस्क्लोजर ऑफ सीक्रेट्स p1
में यहां पे तो ऐसे करके इन्होंने ये पूरा
का पूरा टंग दिया हुआ है उसी तरीके से
नीचे आएंगे तो p2 कैटेगरी शुरू होता है
मिसकॉन्फ़िगर्ड डीएनएस एसएसआरएफ एलएलएम
सिक्योरिटी सॉरी यहां पे ये सारे p2
कैटेगरी में है यहां पे ओ ऑथ मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन p p2 में है यहां पे स्टोर्ड
आपका जो एक्सेसेस है वो p2 में है ये सारी
आपको p2 में आ जाती है फिर से p3 आ जाती
है यहां पे अगेन तो p3 में भी आपका मेल
सर्व मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हो गया एचटीटीपी
रिस्पांस मैनिपुलेशन हो गई कंटेंट
स्पूफिंग हो गई सेशन फिक्सेशन हो गई
डिस्क्लोज ऑफ़ सीक्रेट्स सीक्रेट्स में
किसके लिए फॉर इंटरनल एसेट ठीक है ये
इंटरनल देखो यहां पे सेंसिटिव डाटा
एक्सपोजर में अगर डिस्क्लोजर ऑफ सीक्रेट्स
होगी और इसमें इंटरनल एसेट का होगा तो ये
p3 में आएगा लेकिन ऊपर में त तुम जब जाओगे
एंड यहां पे सेंसिटिव डाटा एक्सपोजर
डिस्क्लोजर ऑफ सीक्रेट्स अगर पब्लिकली
एक्सेसिबल एसेट में आता है जो पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल है उसमें तुम्हें कोई सीक्रेट
मिलता है तो ये p1 कैटेगरी में अब तुम
क्या सोचोगे कि मैंने तो सीक्रेट्स को
डिस्क्लोज किया है मेरा p3 कैसे दे दिया
जबकि यहां तो p1 मेंशन है तो यहां
इन्होंने मेंशन कर रखा है भैया कि यहां पे
किस तरी को किस तरीके की चीज को हम यहां
पे किस कैटेगरी में डाल रहे हैं तो भैया
हमारा जो यहां पे p3 में दिया है
डिस्क्लोजर ऑफ सीक्रेट्स जो है इसमें
इंटरनल एसेट का अगर मैंने कुछ निकाला है
तो फिर वो p3 में आ जाएगा ठीक है उसी
तरीके से यहां पे इन्होंने फिर p4 का दिया
हुआ है यहां पे तो p4 में भी अलग-अलग है
नो रेट लिमिटिंग ऑन फॉर्म फॉर्म ये सब p4
में है लैक ऑफ पासवर्ड कंफर्मेशन कैप्चा
और में ये p4 में आ गया उसके बाद आपका
इंफॉर्मेशन कैटेगरी जो आता है p5 में तो
p5 को बेसिकली क्या करते हैं लो इंपैक्ट
में या इंफॉर्मेशन में माना जाता है इसको
तो यहां पर आपको p5 वाला कैटेगरी जो है
यहां पर आ गई यानी कि पव से लेकर यहां पे
p5 तक की पूरी की पूरी यह कैटेगरी इज जो
है यहां पे की गई है ठीक है तो इस तरीके
से आप इनका वी आईटी सिस्टम देख सकते हैं
उसके बाद यहां पर आपने कोई भी वी आरटी
कैटेगरी सिलेक्ट कर लिया मान लो वी आरटी
टारगेट में अदर किया आपने वी आरटी आपको
करना है सेलेक्ट करना है मान लो यहां पे
तो मान लो मेरे को क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग करनी है तो क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग मान लो कौन स्टोर्ड है
रिफ्लेक्टेड है क्या है तो मान लो नॉन
सेल्फ में रिफ्लेक्टेड है यहां पे तो
मैंने सेलेक्ट कर दिया क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग का नॉन रिफ्लेक्टेड तो ये
नॉन सेल्फ में तो p3 कैटेगरी में आपका
ऑटोमेटिक ये सिलेक्ट हो गया कि ये p3 का
लेबिलिटी है अब यहां पे आना है लेबिलिटी
की डिटेल्स तो अब यूआरएल कौन सा यूआरएल है
जो अफेक्टेड है तो मान लो मेरे को यहां पे
ये वाला यूआरएल मिला था तो मैंने यहां पे
ये यूआरएल यहां पे टेस्ट इज इक्वल टू डाल
दिया तो ये यूआरएल है अब यहां पे आ जाते
हैं डिस्क्रिप्शन फिर वही चीजें आ जाती जो
हमने हैकर वन पे किया था डिस्क्राइब द
सॉरी अरे यार क्या है यार डिस्क्राइब द
वनबिल एंड इट्स इंपैक्ट गिव अ प्रूफ ऑफ
कंसेप्ट और रिप्लिकेशन स्टेप्स ये चीजें
तो अगेन यहां पे इन्होंने पूरा का पूरा ये
हैश हैश करके दिया है इसमें आपको कुछ
ज्यादा नहीं करना है रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस
सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग तो भैया ठीक है
रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग है अब
यहां हैश को हटा दिया ओवरव्यू ऑफ द
अवेलेबिलिटी तो यहां पे ओवरव्यू दे दो या
डिस्क्रिप्शन दे दो यहां पे तुम ओवरव्यू
लिख दो या डिस्क्रिप्शन तो ओवरव्यू रहने
देते हैं ये कर दिया उसके बाद यहां पे
बिजनेस इंपैक्ट यानी कि यानी कि इसका
इंपैक्ट क्या होगा वो कर दिया अब यहां पे
स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस तो यहां पे
स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस बता दिया जो मैंने
अभी बताया था कि इस तरीके से स्टेप्स आपको
लिखने है जो जो मैंने यहां पे आपको बताया
था ना कि किस तरीके से स्टेप्स टू
रीप्रोड्यूस यहां पे करना है कुछ इस तरीके
से तो आपने इस तरीके से स्टेप्स टू
रीप्रोड्यूस यहां पे लिख दिया सेम चीज
यहां पे यहां पे लास्ट में इन्होंने क्या
किया हियर इज हियर इज अ स्क्रीनशॉट ऑफ़ द
फुल एक्सप्लोइट टेबल तो अगर आपके पास कोई
स्क्रीनशॉट है मान लो कोई ऐसा कुछ है कि
आप मेंशन करना चाहो तो आप यहां पे भी डाल
सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है या तो आप
अटैचमेंट में भी डाल सकते हो क्या है यू
कैन अटैच अप टू 20 फाइल्स प्लीज कीप
इंडिविजुअल अपलोड साइज अंडर 400 एबी देख
रहे हो टेक्निकल बंदे लोग एमआईबी लिख रहे
हैं एमबी नहीं लिख रहे हैं मेगा इंटरनेट
बाइट है ये समझ में आ रहा है एमआईबी जो
मैंने बताया हुआ है डीसी जेएसपी वालों को
पता होगा मैं बता रहा हूं ना वही तो बात
है यही तो फर्क है आप किसी डीसी जेएसपी
जिसने सही से ईमानदारी से डीसी डीसी
जेएसपी वाली कोर्स कंप्लीट करी हमारी
ईमानदारी से करिए ऐसे नहीं कि तुक्के में
उध वीडियो एक चार मिनट 4 मिनट पे वीडियो
देख रहे फिर 10 मिनट पे चले गए 6 मिनट में
चले ना एक एक सेकंड स्किप बिना किए देखिए
उससे और किसी दूसरे बंदे से जो नॉन डीसी
जीएसपी होगा उन दोनों को बिठा के और बात
कीजिए आपको फर्क समझ में आएगा कंसेप्ट का
फर्क समझ में आएगा कि क्या उसको पता है
क्या उसको पता है ये मैं ठोक बजा के बोल
सकता हूं ठीक है चलिए क्योंकि उसमें मैंने
ऐसा पढ़ाया ही है खुद से चलिए यहां पे आप
जेपीजी पीएनजी स्मॉलर देन 50mb आप यहां पे
डाल सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां पे
आप डाल के कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो यहां पे
आप अटैचमेंट में इस इंक्लूड या तो अगर
आपका बड़ा फाइल साइज है तो आप वही
ये देखो यहां पे इन्होंने ओवरव्यू में
ऑलरेडी यहां पे दे रखा है इस चीज को तो
यहां पे ओवरव्यू में रहने देते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है यहां पे इसको ऐसे ही रहने
देते हैं बिजनेस इंपैक्ट है यहां पे तो
इंपैक्ट में देखो इन्होंने सब कुछ यहां पे
मेंशन कर रखा है रिफ्लेक्ट ए कुड लीड टू
डेटा थेफ्ट एंड ये सब तो इंपैक्ट भी ये भी
सही है तो यहां भी तुम्हें वैसे ही मिल
गया अब स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस है तो यहां
से तुमने यहां से सीधा कॉपी मारा स्टेप्स
टू रीप्रोड्यूस में क्या
किया यह वाली चीज डाल दी तो तुम्हारा
स्टेप्स टू
जरूर से प्रूफ ऑफ कंसेप्ट है भैया तो यहां
पे प्रूफ ऑफ कंसेप्ट में आपने क्या किया
हियर इज माय हेयर इज माय पीओ वीडियो एंड
यहां पे
google2 ऑफ कंसेप्ट स्क्रिप्ट्स
स्क्रीनशॉट स्क्रीन रिकॉर्डिंग तो इसमें
भी डाल सकते हो ऐसा कुछ नहीं है इसमें भी
डाल सकते हो या
भैया ये इंपैक्टफुल लेबिलिटी अब कई बार
वलने बिलिटी तो होती है लेकिन उसका
इंपैक्ट नहीं पता चल पाता है ठीक है
इंपैक्ट नहीं पता चलेगा तो वो वलने बिलिटी
एक्सेप्ट नहीं करेंगे आप कैसा भी वलने
बिलिटी रिपोर्ट करो अगर वो इंपैक्टफुल
नहीं होगा सामने वाली कंपनी को लगा कि अरे
इसका ये इंपैक्ट तो बता ही नहीं पा रहा
दिखा ही नहीं पा रहा तो वो एक्सेप्ट नहीं
करेंगे तो आपको दिखाना है कि भैया ये
एक्चुअल में इंपैक्टफुल है कि नहीं है
पहले ये सब चीज नहीं होती थी पहले तो वलने
बिटी ऐसे ही एं जिंस का वर्जन डिस्क्लोजर
पे बाउंट मिल जाती थी 5050 बिलीव नहीं
करोगे ऐसा होता था अब तो भाई ये सब चीजें
खत्म ही हो गई है तो और ज्यादा थोड़ी
स्ट्रिक्टनेस आ चुकी है थोड़ी सी
प्रॉब्लेम िक मुश्किल बढ़ा है थोड़ा सा
मुश्किल जो है और आपका बढ़ गया है तो अब
जो है आपको इंपैक्ट दिखाना है हर एक
लेबिलिटी में जो भी है इंपैक्ट दिखाइए
दैट्ची
द चट
गा ए प्लीज टेल मी टेल मी टेल मी टेल मी
हरी अप हरी अप गा हरी अप सभी लोग रिप्लाई
करेंगे तो ही मुझे मजा आएगा जल्दी से
रिप्लाई कर दीजिए
गाइस अब सब लोग को रिपोर्ट राइटिंग में या
रिपोर्ट लिखने में दिक्कत नहीं आने भाई
दिक्कत तो नहीं आएगी
रिपोर्ट लिखने में दिक्कत तो नहीं आएगी
नहीं आएगी ना पक्का ना 100% ना और ये
हमारी वेबसाइट है याद रखिएगा de.com इसको
आप विजिट करते रहिएगा ऑन टाइमली बेसिस
रेगुलर अपडेट के लिए अलग-अलग अपडेट्स के
लिए यहां पे वेबसाइट में आपको मिलती
रहेंगी अलग-अलग इसके सेक्शन को विजिट
कीजिएगा ठीक है याद रखिएगा
सबको बढ़िया बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया बहुत
अच्छी बात है भाई बहुत अच्छी बात है हां
जी वेरी गुड वेरी गुड चलिए यह अच्छी बात
है और फिर से मैं अगेन अगेन मैं फिर से
आपको बोल देता हूं एक बार कि किसी भी किसी
भी वीडियो कोई भी हमारी जो बग बाउंट की
वीडियो चलती है मान लो व्यू मै चैनल पे
चलते हैं कोई भी वीडियो पे उठा लेते हैं
कोई भी वीडियो जैसे अभी आज 41 डे का कल का
40 का कोई भी वीडियो पे जाइएगा इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में चले जाइएगा एंड यहां पे
आप जब जाएंगे तो आपको ऊपर में ही यहां पे
एक
whatsapp2 4000 लोगों ने फॉलो कर रखा है
आप इस पे आ जाइएगा इस पे सबसे पहले आपको
अपडेट्स किसी भी ट्रेनिंग कोर्सेस एंड इस
वीडियो एंड क्लासेस एंड ऑल सबकी सबसे पहले
अपडेट आपको इसी पर मिलेगी सबसे पहले उसके
बाद ही कहीं और मिलेगी आपको अपडेट तो यहां
पे आप जरूर आ जाइएगा इस
समझ में आ गया होगा तो बस आज का सेशन
मैंने पहले ही बोला था कि आज का सेशन
थोड़ा सा स्मॉल होने वाला है लेकिन
जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक के जाइएगा याद रखिएगा
बिना लाइक ठोके जाइएगा देख फिर यह बुरा हो
जाएगा यह गलत हो जाएगा ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं रूट काली whatsapp-web
ठीक है सब चीज आएंगी पहले एपीआई पन
टेस्टिंग के पहले एपीआई को तो समझना
पड़ेगा ना यार एपीआई पहले तो नॉर्मल एपीआई
समझने पड़ेंगे किस तरह से एपीआई कॉल्स
होते हैं किस तरह से एपीआई से इंटरेक्शन
होती है कैसे स इंटरेक्ट करता है सर्वर से
तो सब कुछ पहले समझेंगे फिर उस पे भी
आएंगे ठीक है न्यू अनाउंसमेंट आएगी आएगी
भाई धन्यवाद चलिए धन्यवाद सभी लोगों का
एंड आप सब आए बहुत मजा आया एंड आज की
क्लास को हम यहीं पे समाप्त करते हैं
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में बहुत जल्द एक
नए टॉपिक और इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक के साथ एंड
आप सबसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि जितनी जल्दी खत्म
कर सकते हैं कीजिए एक बात याद रखिएगा कि
नई-नई टॉपिक्स अभी हम लेकर आ रहे हैं तो
अगर किसी ने पुरानी वीडियोस या क्लासेस
नहीं भी देखी है तो भी अभी करंट वाली जो
क्लासेस होती हैं उसको देख सकता है अटेंड
कर सकता है लिंक्ड नहीं है अभी की कोई भी
क्लासेस प्रीवियस क्लासेस से ठीक है पार्ट
वाइज आती है वही लिंक्ड होती है बाकी कोई
लिंक नहीं होती है तो आप करंट वाली को
फॉलो कर सकते हो प्रीवियस को फॉलो करते
हुए चलिए तो सेशन को यहां पे एंड करते हैं
गाइ बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद आप सब यहां पे हैं
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
जाते-जाते इस वीडियो को शेयर कीजिए अपने
दोस्तों के बीच में एंड लाइक करते हुए
जाइएगा धन्यवाद